la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à protéger
les logements contre l'occupation
illicite
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
Gasparian rapporteur de la commission
des affaires économiques pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues
Cécilia en procédure avec ses locataires
depuis six ans a dû déménager dans une
petite maison rurale elle n'arrivait
plus à faire face aux 75000 euros d'un
pays 25000 euros de charges 7000 euros
d'honoraires d'avocats que du coup de
son appartement occupé en région
parisienne
Mégane dans la Somme qui a hérité de la
maison de sa mère décédée en février est
actuellement hébergé par des amis sa
maison est occupée par un locataire qui
ne paye plus son loyer depuis 15 mois
pierre et Maryse à Marseille ont dû
vivre dans un camping-car pendant plus
de deux ans il n'arrivait plus à vivre
décemment car leur locataire n'avait pas
réglé de loyer depuis deux ans
nous avons tous déjà reçu dans nos
permanences en circonscription des
petits propriétaires qui ne roulent pas
sur l'or ils ont parfois hérité de la
maison familiale ils ont parfois acheté
ce bien à la sueur de leur front ils se
sont parfois endettés pour financer ce
logement et il se retrouve du jour au
lendemain victime de squat ou de
procédures kafkaïenne en raison d'un
pays qui dure depuis des années
j'en profite pour remercier vivement les
nombreuses personnes qui ont fait
l'effort de nous envoyer un témoignage
écrit en quelques jours nous en avons
reçu près de 200 je remercie également
la dizaine de victimes qui ont fait
l'effort de venir parfois de loin
parfois en se levant à 3 heures du matin
témoigner devant notre commission ces
situations elles sont insupportables
d'une part car elle prolonge et elle
plonge dans la précarité des citoyens
pourtant qui travaillent dur et qui
respectent les règles d'autre part car
elle touche un principe fondamental que
certains ont parfois tendance à oublier
celui du respect de droit de propriété
droit inviolable et sacré inscrit à
l'article 17 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme
face à ces situations intolérables qui
est gratine et graines nos actualités
locales et suscitent l'indignation de
nos concitoyens nous avons déjà agi avec
fermeté après la création d'une
procédure accélérée d'expulsion des
squatteurs en 2007 celle-ci n'avait plus
été modifiée et fonctionnait mal nous
avons repris le sujet dans la loi ASAP
en 2020 ce qui nous a permis de mener à
bien 170 expulsions de squatteurs sur ce
fondement en 2021 mais l'actualité nous
a montré maintes et maintes fois qu'il
faut aller plus loin ou en tout cas
aborder plus globalement le problème
c'est ce que permet cette proposition de
loi du groupe Renaissance que nous
examinons aujourd'hui la première partie
du texte a d'ailleurs été largement
enrichi en commission notamment avec des
apports de nos collègues des groupes
Renaissance CLR de nouveaux articles ont
été créés qui permettent entre autres de
mieux caractériser le délit de squat et
de veiller à protéger les propriétaires
contre les dépenses d'entretien
excessive qui sont nés des situations de
squat deux autres articles permettent
d'améliorer la lutte contre les
marchands de sommeil et en sanctionnant
les faux propriétaires qui exploitent
les une vulnérable et de renforcer la
lutte contre le squat en assurant une
meilleure utilisation collective des
immeubles vacants au-delà de ces cas de
squat toute une zone grise n'est pas
traitée par le biais des procédures
existantes je pense par exemple au refus
de payer partiellement ou dans son
intégralité de loyer qui peut grever
pendant des mois ou des années la
situation financière d'un petit bailleur
dans le logement constitue un complément
de retraite ou encore le refus des de
quitter les lieux en fin de bail quand
le bailleur souhaite récupérer pour
lui-même ou pour un membre de sa famille
contraignant ainsi le bailleur à
déménager ou à faire héberger ses
enfants oui la plupart des locations se
passent très bien et pour elle la
propager de loi n'aura aucun impact mais
pour mieux protéger tous les autres
locataires
il faut que nous agissions nous devons
protéger contre les comportements
abusifs de la part d'une minorité de
locataires qui doivent être mieux
sanctionnées ces comportements
augmentent l'appréhension et les
exigences des bailleurs ou décourage des
bailleurs de mettre en location leur
bien si nous avons un marché locatif
tellement engorgé par des demandes dans
tous les sens par des certificats des
garanties des cautions des attestations
des justificatifs c'est qu'il n'y a pas
assez de confiance entre les bailleurs
et les locataires si nous réussissons à
rétablir cette confiance il deviendra
vite possible de diminuer les exigences
des bailleurs ce qui savent cette
confiance ce sont les cas d'une minorité
de locataires indélicat qui continue
d'occuper un logement parfois malgré la
décision d'un juge de rompre le bail et
de procéder à l'expulsion qui en payent
les conséquences l'immense majorité des
locataires bon payeurs
au-delà de leurs coups humains immédiat
les lenteurs et les manques de
réactivité des procédures tout au long
du règlement des conflits dans les
rapports locatifs entame la confiance
qu'on en concitoyens dans la justice et
dans nos institutions c'est la raison
pour laquelle la proposition de loi
traite des relations entre le locataire
et le bailleur ces dernières années nous
avons porté une grande attention à la
sécurisation des locataires
l'encadrement des loyers en zone tendue
que nous avons créé en 2018 dans la loi
Elan il a été prorogé jusqu'en 2026 par
la loi 3DS en février dernier nous avons
étendu visale lancé aussi en 2018 pour
permettre un cautionnement plus fiable
des locataires encore il y a quelques
mois dans la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
nous avons plafonné l'évolution de la
hausse des loyers en dessous du niveau
de l'inflation nous attendons aussi des
efforts importants des propriétaires en
matière de mise à niveau énergétique du
parc locatif je rappelle que toutes les
passoires thermiques seront concernées
d'ici 2025 et 2028 c'est-à-dire au bas
mot 1,5 millions de logements dans le
parc locatif privé
la proposition de l'Ouest s'inscrit donc
dans la recherche d'un équilibre entre
les protections accordées au locataires
et les efforts supplémentaires demandés
au bailleur dans un contexte tendu il
est important d'envoyer un signal au
bailleur afin de ne pas désinciter leurs
investissements c'est d'autant plus vrai
que les options s'offrant aux
investisseurs sont simples à réaliser à
commencer par le parc des meublés de
tourisme ou celui des résidences
services voilà pourquoi il me semble
impératif d'agir avec vigueur pour
remédier à ses injustices et c'est le
sens de cette proposition de loi nous ne
supprimons aucune des étapes de la
procédure du contentieux locatif nous
proposons simplement des accélérations
de procédure pour aller plus vite vers
des décisions exécutoires car nous
pensons que les procès et procédures qui
durent des années et des années ne sont
positifs pour personne en commission de
nombreux amendements ont renforcé le
texte en favorisant l'accélération des
procédures nous avons également amélioré
la capacité du juge à apprécier la
situation du locataire pour distinguer
entre celui qui est de bonne foi et
celui qui est de mauvaise foi et c'est
un travail que je l'espère nous vont
pouvoir poursuivre en séance comme en
commission les amendements déposés pour
la séance témoignent de position
idéologique qui peuvent être
radicalement différentes en lisant
certains amendements des groupes LFI et
écologistes j'ai l'impression que
certains veulent défendre les squats
allonger les procédures ou simplement de
veulent pas parler de ces petits
propriétaires en difficulté aux
simplement motifs qu'ils sont
propriétaires mais chers collègues une
grande majorité d'entre vous ont déposé
des amendements qui attestent de la
volonté du législateur de renforcer la
protection du domicile de sanctionner
sévèrement le squat d'accélérer les
procédures et de faire tout ce qui est
en notre pouvoir pour répondre à ces
situations de détresse psychologique et
sociales quand bien même elle serait
minoritaire
celles et ceux d'entre vous qui ont reçu
un jour dans leur permanence un citoyen
dans le domicile esquatté ou un
propriétaire dont le bien est occupé par
un locataire qui ne paye plus depuis des
années savent que la situation actuelle
ne peut plus durer nous avons le devoir
d'agir c'est ce qu'attendent les
victimes c'est ce qu'attendent les
Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministres de la justice
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre cher Olivier
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques
mesdames et messieurs les députés
alors que ce sont multipliés récemment
les exemples médiatisés de
petits propriétaires
laissés dans l'incapacité de récupérer
un logement
votre proposition monsieur le rapporteur
apporte une réponse indispensable à ces
situations qui choque et à juste titre
d'ailleurs nos concitoyens
je vais donc saluer ici votre initiative
qui s'est inscrite en synergie avec les
travaux de la Chancellerie notamment sur
la redéfinition de la notion de domicile
afin de mieux réprimer les squats
qui ne sont aujourd'hui plus tolérables
je veux être d'emblée très clair
il s'agit pas ici
de favoriser de riches propriétaires des
rentiers qui exploiteraient des gens
démunis mais bien tout simplement de
faire respecter notre droit et de faire
cesser l'affaissement de l'autorité de
l'État que toutes les affaires
médiatisées ont gravement mis à mal
ces situations ont souvent mis en
lumière des petits propriétaires ayant
économisé toute leur vie pour acquérir
un bien
et il se retrouve dans l'impossibilité
de récupérer le fruit de leur travail et
de leurs économies je pense en
particulier à l'exemple d'une vieille
dame
vivant dans un EHPAD qui s'est retrouvé
dans l'incapacité de récupérer son
appartement
squatter qu'elle souhaitait vendre pour
payer les mensualités de son EHPAD et
assuré au fond ainsi sa fin de vie
impossible impossible de récupérer son
bien car oui l'appartement était
occupé squatté de façon illégale cette
situation elle est intolérable et porte
gravement atteinte à notre pacte social
et républicain qui veut que les citoyens
s'en remettent aux autorités tout
simplement pour faire respecter la loi
oui je pense qu'il n'est pas tolérable
qu'une dame âgée angoisse à l'idée de ne
plus pouvoir payer ses traites parce
qu'elle ne peut pas récupérer son bien
acquis à la sueur de son front
je le dis tout net la lutte contre les
squats
et nécessaire
je le dis tout net la lutte contre les
squats nous amènent à ce que
force doit rester à la loi et je précise
que on l'espèce la loi doit d'abord
protéger les gens honnêtes
je suis en effet particulièrement
sensible à ces situations qui sont des
situations individuelles qui concernent
avant tout la vie quotidienne de femmes
et d'hommes une vie quotidienne que nous
essayons chacun à notre niveau
d'améliorer chaque jour
non le logement n'est pas un lieu ou un
bien matériel comme les autres
c'est le lieu de l'intime du repos c'est
le lieu de la famille
et il convient de le protéger contre les
atteintes qui peuvent y être portées
j'ai examiné en détail la proposition de
loi et je salue votre travail monsieur
le Président gaz barian ainsi que celui
de la commission des affaires
économiques avant de vous livrer mon
avis sur chacune des dispositions
qu'elle comporte je voudrais
faire quelques rappels généraux
la protection du droit de propriété
figure effectivement au nombre des
droits de l'homme
consacrés par les articles 2 et 17 de la
Déclaration de 1789
mais ce n'est pas le droit de propriété
que protège aujourd'hui le délit de
l'article de 126-4 du code pénal mais le
domicile
comme émanation du droit au respect de
la vie privée
et
ce respect de la vie privée
constitutionnellement et
conventionnellement garantie c'est
l'objet du délit de violation de
domicile depuis 2015
l'article
226-4
distingue expressément deux infractions
dont celle de maintien dans le domicile
d'autrui qui présente la particularité
d'être une infraction continue et non
une infraction instantanée comme les
l'introduction dans le domicile d'autrui
cette particularité fait que les forces
de l'ordre peuvent tout au long de
l'occupation intervenir et interpeller
les squatteurs peu importe le délai
écoulé 48 heures ou plus depuis leur
introduction dans le domicile cette
infraction est donc un outil juridique
efficace puissant pour permettre de
faire cesser les situations de squat
caractérisées j'insiste sur ce fait car
il est trop souvent cité des cas dans la
presse de français partie en vacances
qui ne peuvent pas récupérer leur
domicile car plus de 48 heures seraient
passées
votre proposition de loi
propose d'augmenter les peines encourus
pour la violation domicile afin de les
aligner sur celles encourues par le
propriétaire qui par exemple rentre chez
lui
à l'aide de manœuvre dans le but bien
sûr de récupérer son bien
c'est le monde à l'envers
c'est le monde à l'envers et et pire que
cela
des informations me sont remontées selon
lesquelles le squatteur a le cynisme
parfois de faire afficher sur la fenêtre
du domicile qui l'occupe les pénalités
qui seraient encourues par le
propriétaire on marche sur la tête
je suis donc et vous l'avez compris mais
tout à fait favorable à cet alignement
dans l'échelle des peines il me semble
en effet nécessaire et ça permet de
répondre à une situation qu'on ne peut
tous que qualifier de totalement injuste
je suis en revanche il fallait un bémol
un peu plus réservé sur l'article 2 de
la proposition de loi qui vise à
clarifier les notions utilisées dans
l'infraction de violation de missiles en
élargissant la notion de domicile à
celle de domicile vide
de meubles à cet égard un bien
immobilier ne peut être considéré comme
un domicile s'il ne comporte pas des
éléments minimaux nécessaires à
l'habitation ça soulève des difficultés
d'ordre constitutionnel car portant
atteinte au sens du délit de violation
domicile qui vise à protéger je l'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure la vie privée est
familiale et non pas le droit de
propriété l'extension de la notion de
domicile à la résidence secondaire ne
poser en revanche pas de problème car le
domicile est déjà interprété de cette
manière par la jurisprudence j'ai donc
bon espoir que nos débats nous
permettront d'avancer sur ce point
je vais également
faire par ici
de mes fortes réserves quant à l'article
1a des travaux de votre commission qui
prévoit la création d'un délit général
d'occupation sans droit nitres de
mauvaise foi d'un immeuble d'habitation
en premier lieu il présente
d'importantes fragilités
constitutionnelle au regard du principe
de l'égalité des délits qui impose en
effet de définir clairement le champ
d'application de l'infraction et vous
m'accorderez que le terme de mauvaise
foi ne fait pas l'objet d'une définition
en droit pénale en deuxième la mauvaise
foi oui je le confirme monsieur le
député Maya ça existe partout d'ailleurs
sauf dans l'hémicycle naturellement
en deuxième lieu le champ d'application
de ce daily m'apparaît trop large voir
excessif ce délit aurait également pour
effet d'incriminer les locataires
défaillants qui ne font l'objet d'aucune
mesure d'expulsion y compris y compris
pendant la trêve hivernale et y compris
si aucune procédure d'expulsion n'a été
lancé à leur rencontre enfin en dernier
lieu cet article procède un grand
versement de la charge de la preuve et
instaure de ce fait une présomption de
culpabilité un tel dispositif présente
un risque constitutionnel extrêmement
important
en complément
des outils offerts par notre procédure
pénale nous disposons de deux voies pour
expulser le squatteur du logement
d'autrui une voie civile une voie
administrative la voici ville permet de
saisir le juge des référés celui-ci
lorsqu'il constate l'existence d'un
trouble manifestement-il licite
c'est-à-dire l'occupation du bien peut
ordonner les mesures conservatoires qui
s'imposent y compris l'expulsion selon
les données statistiques de 2021 le
délai moyen de traitement d'une demande
d'expulsion d'un squatteur devant le
juge judiciaire et de 5 mois nous
disposons également depuis la loi DALO
du 5 mars 2007 d'une procédure
administrative d'exécution forcée
celle-ci permet dans son article 38 au
préfet lorsqu'une plainte a été déposée
pour violation de domicile d'ordonner
l'expulsion des squatteurs sans attendre
qu'une décision judiciaire soit rendue
à la suite de l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi ASAP qui est venu compléter la loi
DALO nous avons pris l'initiative avec
mes collègues des ministères de
l'Intérieur et du Logement d'adresser le
22 janvier 2021 une instruction au
préfet pour détailler la mise en œuvre
de cette procédure et les enjoindre à
assurer la rapidité de son exécution
plus que jamais l'exécutif est donc
mobilisé pour lutter contre les squats
la présence proposition de loi en tant
renforcer la procédure administrative
afin de faciliter l'expulsion des
occupants sans droit ni titres il me
semble toutefois nécessaire de veiller à
ce que ces nouveaux dispositifs ne
puissent pas avoir des conséquences sur
les locataires de bonne foi qui peuvent
se trouver dans une situation économique
délicate et qu'il est indispensable de
ne pas pointer du doigt dans un contexte
économique incertain c'est pourquoi il
est indispensable de garder à l'esprit
que notre droit civil veille à aménager
les droits des locataires qui ne paient
plus leur loyer en permettant notamment
au juge après la délivrance d'un
commandement de quitter les lieux
d'octroyer de façon exceptionnelle des
délais supplémentaires afin de permettre
à des familles en situation de précarité
de se reloger dans des conditions dignes
le droit civil fait également obstacle
aux expulsions durant la trêve hivernale
c'est qui non négligeable j'insiste sur
ce point car la loi veille ainsi à
répondre à des situations individuelles
qui peuvent se révéler dramatiques et il
n'apparaît pas souhaitable que la
légitime lutte contre les squatteurs
conduisent à modifier ses équilibres à
ce titre votre proposition de loi
prévoit la réduction de certains délais
de procédures destinés à accélérer le
traitement de ses affaires il ne
bouleverse pas l'équilibre des droits en
présence et j'y suis donc tout à fait
favorable cette recherche d'équilibre se
retrouve également dans les textes
actuels entre le dispositif pénal qui
réprime la violation de domicile et
l'article 38 de la loi DALO s'agissant
des propriétaires il est important de
sécuriser leur situation face à des
occupations illicites de leurs biens et
donc de les charger dans certaines
circonstances de leur responsabilité
c'est ce quand on fait l'article 2 bis
de la proposition de loi il me semble
donc indispensable que nous puissions
parvenir dans le respect de nos
principes constitutionnels à trouver un
équilibre entre la défense de la
propriété immobilière qui concerne aussi
des petits propriétaires et le droit au
logement c'est tout le sens des débats
que nous allons avoir aujourd'hui et qui
sont je le crois absolument nécessaire
avant de laisser la parole à mon ami et
collègue Olivier Klein qui nous
éclairera sur le volet logement du texte
je voudrais saluer l'esprit de
co-construction qui a présidé à la
conception de cette proposition voici
vous remercier monsieur le Président gaz
barian je remercier les groupes de
l'opposition je pense au groupe les
républicains Eliott mais aussi ceux de
la majorité bien sûr
qui ont participé à l'amélioration de ce
texte et je pense en particulier à votre
collègue pôle midi mais également
Philippe Pradal et enfin les députés du
groupe modem je l'ai dit dans la lutte
contre les squats ce texte est une
nouvelle étape intéressante faisons en
sorte tous ensemble
ça arrive ça nous est arrivé il y a de
cela quelques jours je devrais dire
quelques heures qu'il apporte ce texte
des solutions efficaces concrètes
respectueuse de nos grands principes
constitutionnels voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés ce que trop
longuement sans doute je vous les
exprimer pour le gouvernement
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du logement
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux chez Eric monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui traite de situation humaine
souvent complexe
dans sa première partie il traite du
sujet inacceptable des squats je connais
votre attachement monsieur le rapporteur
cher président kasbariian à résoudre des
situations inacceptables et
insupportables comme la rappeler le
garde des sceaux
je salue d'ailleurs à ce titre
l'introduction d'un amendement en
commission par le groupe Renaissance
visant à sanctionner pénalement les
marchands de sommeil ceux qui indument
organisent des squats en faisant croire
qu'ils sont propriétaires des logements
en toute illégalité et au détriment des
plus faibles
c'est inacceptable et le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisé contre ce
phénomène cela s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans
la lutte du gouvernement contre
l'habitat indigne dont les procédures
ont été renforcées et simplifiées par la
loi Elan adopter lors de la précédente
législature
toutefois il nous faut aussi chercher
les moyens de mobiliser les locaux
vacances qui peuvent offrir légalement
un toit à ceux qui en ont besoin cette
proposition de loi propose ainsi de
prolonger le dispositif expérimental qui
permet un propriétaire de confier un
local vacant à une association pendant
une durée donnée pour y accueillir et
héberger celles et ceux qui en ont
besoin
et je sais que la discussion va nous
permettre d'évoquer la pérennisation de
ce dispositif social
cette proposition de loi prévoit dans un
deuxième temps un durcissement du droit
existant à l'encontre des locataires
mauvais payeurs et je tiens ici à être
clair d'abord l'assimilation entre un
squatteur et locataire mauvais payeur
n'a pas lieu d'être il s'agit de
situations très différentes
j'ai toutefois bien sûr conscience que
nous parlons ici de situation humaine
toujours très complexe dans le cas des
impayés de loyer ce texte doit
s'inscrire dans la recherche d'un
équilibre car sur ce sujet l'enjeu est
double d'un côté sécurisez les bailleurs
car le parc locatif est essentiel dans
le parcours résidentiel de l'autre
accompagner les locataires en difficulté
avec des outils adaptés
notre politique c'est la prévention des
expulsions de nombreux outils sont
développés pour accompagner les
locataires en difficulté et ne jamais
arriver à l'expulsion
en amont des procédures des outils de
prévention sont déployés dans le cadre
du plan interministériel de prévention
des expulsions vous le savez des équipes
me dit mobiles de 70 juristes et
travailleurs sociaux financés par l'État
rencontre les locataires en difficulté
dans de nombreux départements le fond de
solidarité logement le FSL géré par les
Conseils départementaux et financés en
partie par l'État accompagne également
les locataires et ce soutien est
d'autant plus vrai dans la période
actuelle comme la rappeler le garde des
sceaux de hausse des charges au-delà des
boucliers tarifaires de la limitation de
la hausse de loyer et de
l'accompagnement mise en place par le
gouvernement notamment avec le chèque
énergie
notre objectif c'est évidemment que la
hausse des charges n'entraîne aucune
expulsion locative d'ailleurs je veux
rappeler ici que j'ai demandé au CAF de
continuer avec les APL les APL pardon
pour tous les locataires de bonne foi en
impayé de loyer
ces outils
reflètent l'équilibre que nous cherchons
ainsi je veux rappeler que les
propriétaires bailleurs peuvent être
indemnisés lorsque l'état n'accorde pas
le concours à la force publique
et ses efforts paient j'ai présidé le
droit novembre dernier l'Observatoire
des impayés de loyer aucune hausse
significative des impayés n'a été relevé
même si notre vigilance doit rester
constante le nombre d'expulsions
locatives ne reflète pas la crainte
d'explosion de ces situations que la
crise du covid notamment avait pu
alimenter
c'est donc au regard de ces résultats
que je crois très important de conserver
tous les efforts faits dans la
prévention des expulsions locatives il
faut laisser le temps du travail social
il faut laisser au juge le pouvoir
d'analyser chaque situation d'être au
plus proche des réalités difficiles
d'une expulsion qui est toujours un
échec
et cela sera une préoccupation constante
dans l'examen de cette proposition de
loi et notamment de son article 5
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit donc
dans cette logique d'équilibre je tiens
à rappeler que nous disposons déjà d'un
arsenal juridique et de procédures qui
visent à le préserver
cette proposition souhaite aller plus
loin ce que le Gouvernement partage à
certaines conditions
comme je l'ai dit il y a bien sûr la
poursuite du travail de prévention le
troisième plan interministériel de
prévention des expulsions en cours
jusqu'à la fin 2023 traduit d'ailleurs
cette mobilisation du gouvernement
je le répète l'équilibre est essentiel
l'équilibre apaise le marché évite des
cautions toujours plus importantes des
assurances toujours plus cher mais il
doit pas se faire en ignorant les
situations humaines des locataires les
ruptures les heures je sais que ces
messages est entendu je crois qu'il est
partagé et j'ai confiance dans les
débats qui auront lieu dans les
prochaines heures pour atteindre cette
équilibre dans ces conditions le
gouvernement donnera donc un avis
favorable à cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nue une motion de rejet
préalable déposée en application de
l'article 91 à l'ina5 du règlement la
parole est à Monsieur François Piquemal
pour une durée maximale de 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous
n'accepterons pas que l'on considère
comme découpable ceux qui dans la
nécessité d'éviter la maladie et
peut-être la mort
occupe des logements vacants ces mots ne
sont pas de nous ils sont dans la
relation collègues qui siégeait ici son
nom c'était Henri gouas il était plus
connu sous le nom de l'abbé Pierre ces
mots il les prononça un jour de décembre
1994 rue du Dragon à Paris alors qu'il
venait soutenir des militants du droit
au logement et des familles qui avaient
réquisitionné un bâtiment vide de la
Cogedim
ces mots de l'unbé Pierre il les dit
parce qu'il disait à ce genre que leur
cause était juste et que quand les
institutions ne font rien il n'y a
d'autre choix que de s'abriter là où
l'on peut en introduisant le fait
qu'occuper tout type de logement
vacances à parent à vol avec 3 ans à 15
ans de prison ferme vous glissez
monsieur le rapporteur sur une pente
dangereuse qui n'est pas contrairement à
ce que vous avancez la protection des
petits propriétaires mais la
criminalisation de tous les mal logés
autrement dit
si votre loi était passée jadis l'abbé
Pierre serait en prison pourtant nous
aurions espéré que dans un pays qui
compte 4,1 million de mal logés 3005 ans
sans abri dont 42000 enfants SDF vous
nous proposeriez enfin une loi à la
hauteur des enjeux de mal logement au
lieu de quoi va priorité de répondre à
la médiatisation constante c'est dans
l'exposé des motifs d'un épiphénomène
les affaires de squat ne concernent que
0,05% des logements recensés dans ce
pays
170 affaires par an c'est autant que le
nombre de députés Renaissance
170 affaires par an c'est 100 fois moins
que les expulsions locatives madame
wargon elle-même ministre du Logement a
signifié que c'était un problème mineur
qui ne méritait pas
d'instrumentalisation politique madame
Causse ancienne ministre du Logement dit
de votre loi qu'elle va déréguler des
années de travail sur la prévention des
impulsion vous devriez leur prêter une
oreille plus attentive qu'aux éditoriaux
de cnews oui il est évident ici pour
tout le monde qu'il est inacceptable de
rentrer chez soi et découvrir des gens
qui s'y sont installés c'est tellement
inacceptable que nos anciens ont déjà
légiféré sur le sujet ça a été dit avec
une loi qui sanctionne au cas où
l'occupation du domicile d'autrui avec
un an de prison et 15000 euros d'amende
la loi actuelle prévoit d'ailleurs son
délai l'expulsion des gens occupant le
démocratie le domicile résidence
secondaire ou principale la notion de
domicile est ainsi protégée nettement et
ce n'est pas de ce type de squat dans ce
préoccupe d'ailleurs votre loi non c'est
surtout toutes les autres personnes qui
sont juridiquement sans droit ni titre
et victime du mal logement qui sont
visés qui protéger vous réellement pas
les petits retraités propriétaires
bailleurs comme vous dites sinon vous
auriez proposé la garantie universelle
des loyers où l'augmentation des
pensions de retraite non vous protéger
les intérêts des multipropriétaires qui
détiennent à eux seuls plus de 75% du
parc locatif cela car avec votre loi le
domicile est désormais dissocié de la
notion de lieu de vie un gros
propriétaire pour la prétendre qu'un
logement vide non meublé ou encore des
immeubles de bureau vacances les salades
abandons sans son domicile bienvenue en
absurdistant vous introduisez ici une
nouvelle définition du domicile
dangereuse qui casse les codes
juridiques admis mais qui posent aussi
une question de rapport au logement
global vous devriez à ce sujet lire le
livre de Mona Cholet chez soi qui
revient notamment sur ce qu'est le
domicile c'est un lieu de vie
seul ou accompagné on y est c'est là où
on bâtit une famille où sont les
premiers pas des enfants où l'on se
retrouve autour d'un repas où l'on se
réfugie quand ça ne va pas c'est à toi
au dessus de sa tête et le parfum des
siens être chez soi ce n'est pas un
logement laissé vide sans meuble sans
âme avec pour seul fonction de servir de
bien de spéculation c'est un lieu où se
joue aussi les rapports de domination
entre les hommes et les femmes qu'il
convient de combattre pour viser à une
égalité entre les sexes le logement est
d'ailleurs souvent à la charge de la
femme a signé aux tâches domestiques par
les stigmates patriarco qui perdurent
dans notre société beaucoup
d'associations de mal logés vous le
diront quand un problème de logement
survient c'est sur la femme que repose
le poids des problèmes sans prendre ici
aux personnes en difficulté de logement
c'est aussi sans prendre majoritairement
aux femmes
[Musique]
voici désormais quelques exemples
concrets reçus dans nos permanences de
gens qui avec votre loi vont se
retrouver comme squatteurs et même
voleur guillaume est étudiant en droit
arrivé dans une grande ville qu'il ne
connaît pas il a trouvé un logement une
sous-location un jour la personne qui
lui sous le logement lui dit que le
propriétaire doit récupérer son bien
d'ici un mois congés vente Guillaume
fait une demande HLM cherche un logement
mais les prix des loyers la caution les
feuilles de salaire sur trois
générations qu'on lui demande Guillaume
n'y arrive pas il stresse tous les
matins de se retrouver à la rue mais ne
peut faire autrement selon vous
Guillaume est-il un squatteur Aurore à
71 ans elle est retraitée mais ne s'en
sort pas avec ses 900 euros par mois et
un loyer qui augmente chaque année à
payer procédure d'expulsion elle est
reconnue expulsable aurore est allé
voleuse
Elisabeth et son fils Bruno lou de
manière informelle un logement à
marchand de sommeil qui les arnaque ils
sont prioritaires DALO mais attendent
toujours sont-ils pour autant
d'exploitateurs
non je vous invite je vous invite s'il
vous plaît à écouter l'orateur
et si vous souhaitez si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges en bilatérale vous
sortez de l'hémicycle et vous allez
poursuivre la discussion en dehors de
l'hémicycle
monsieur Piquemal vous avez la parole et
vous merci chacun des collègues du
groupe promenais de sens peut venir me
voir après plutôt que de petits vers la
tribune je finis mes exemples Emmanuel
et licencié de son travail il doit
quitter son logement de fonction mais il
ne sait pas où traverser la rue pour
trouver un abri Emmanuel est-il un
voleur voilà où vous menez vos exemples
absurdes j'en prends un dernier
5 novembre 2018 Marseille quartier de
Noailles rue d'Aubagne
les bâtiments du 63 et 65 s'effondre
Julien Taher Sheriff Fabien Simona niacé
Ouloum marie-emmanuel 8 personnes 8
personnes sont mortes du mal logement
après la catastrophe le Haut Comité pour
le logement de rendra public un rapport
Marseille de la crise du logement à la
crise humanitaire il y a constaté que
les effondrements rudobagne ne sont pas
le fait divers accidentel mais résulte
d'une continuité de dysfonctionnement
des acteurs publics mairie état en tête
des élus les républicains sont épinglés
pour la location ou la vente de
logements insalubre car oui au 65 rue
d'aubargne des personnes étaient
victimes de marchands de sommeil avec
votre loi ces personnes auraient été
considérées comme des squatteuses et des
voleuses et nous assisterions à cette
situation indigne où les propriétaires
voyous auraient pu se retourner contre
leur victime pour leur imputer
dégradation de Lior immeuble il y a un
an c'était encore 1500 personnes
évacuées suite au drame de Noailles qui
vivait toujours dans des logements
temporaires parfois précaires dont ils
sont souvent occupants son droit inutile
dites-nous monsieur le rapporteur ces
personnes pour vous sont-elles des
squatteuses et des voleuses votre loi en
réalité visée essentiellement à protéger
les multipropriétaires qui spéculent sur
le logement je vais vous raconter une
histoire advenu dans ma ville de
Toulouse chacun qui allait dans la ville
rose connaît la place Saint-Pierre c'est
bar traditionnel et à quelques pas de là
il y a un grand bâtiment de 4500 m², qui
s'appelle le cassis le saint-pierre face
à la Garonne qui appartient désormais à
la société Cogedim celle tient un projet
immobilier qui est décrit sur leur site
je cite votre résidence service senior
Cogedim club Ali adresse prestigieuse et
services haut de gamme un emplacement
incomparable conjuguant sécurité
rentabilité et optimisation fiscale il
faut que je vous raconte comment cet
immeuble qui évite depuis 10 ans est
arrivé dans les mains de la Cogedim il
appartenait un moment à la métropole de
Toulouse qu'il a laissé un promoteur
immobilier en 2004 pour 4,75 millions
d'euros 6 ans plus tard l'immeuble était
toujours vide se promoteur la vendu à la
Cogedim 11 millions d'euros en 6 ans il
a fait un bénéfice de 6 millions d'euros
sur un bâtiment qu'il a laissé sciemment
vacant pour spéculer
la semaine dernière nous avons appris
grâce à la police judiciaire que je
salue qu'il était mis en garde à vue
avec d'autres manières de l'immobilier
dans une affaire d'escroquerie dont un
des leviers était la spéculation
locative le rapport c'est que ce genre
d'individu que votre loi va protéger
ces individus qui spéculent sur les
logements vides sur les loyers sur le
dos de nos anciens des locataires des
personnes qui sont fragilité par rapport
au logement dans ce pays cela dans un
pays qui compte 3,1 millions de
logements vacants en 20 ans ces derniers
ont augmenté de
55%. il n'y a que les supers profits du
CAC 40 qui vont aussi vite et ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas sans corrélation en 2016
la rapporte spéciale de l'ONU au
logement les ilanifara décrivait comment
des grosses sociétés immobilières
captaient des immeubles de logement et
de bureau qui laissaient vacants exprès
pour spéculer dessus alors on peut on
peut se demander dans cette loi quelles
sont les mesures que vous avez mises en
place pour lutter contre cela aidez-vous
les petits propriétaires d'ailleurs pour
rénover leur logement et les remettre en
location allez-vous taxer les
multipropriétaires qui laissent
sciemment des logements vides
comptez-vous utiliser la loi de
réquisition rien de tout ça pourtant la
loi de Ré fait pleinement partie de
notre histoire républicaine elle a été
mise en place par le général de Gaulle
après-guerre elle a été utilisée pour
accueillir les Pieds-Noirs venus
d'Algérie et par des gouvernements de
gauche comme de droite mais vous n'en
parlez jamais je me permets donc de vous
glisser ses paroles du rappeur Nekfeu
qui pourront peut-être vous y faire
penser dehors c'est froid il n'y a plus
d'humanité un homme est mort inanimé
devant un immeuble inhabité toutes les
heures toutes les cinq heures pardon
dans ce pays une personne meurt à la rue
pour un sans-abris dans ce pays il y a
10 logements qui sont vides votre loi
prétend lutter contre les squatteurs
mais on l'a vu cette dénomination
reflète de nombreuses réalités que vous
n'avez même pas pris la peine d'étudier
vous auriez pu auditionner d'une victime
de marchands de sommeil des locataires
en difficulté des locataires victimes
d'escrocs des gens s'étant réfugiés par
nécessité dans un logement vide vous
n'avez rien fait de tout cela vous avez
choisi de l'immobilier et de la
spéculation à l'heure où les locataires
voient les charges d'énergie augmenter
vous allez ajouter une pression
dangereuse sur les 4 millions de mal
logés de notre pays et c'est là le grand
paradoxe c'est que vous créez cette loi
dans avec cette loi les conditions pour
que davantage de personnes se retrouvent
à la rue ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
mais un responsable du Secours
Catholique et soit tenté d'entrer dans
un des trois millions de logements vides
de notre pays les squats c'est votre
inaction en matière de politique de
logement qui en est le terreau c'est le
manque de moyens pour les travailleurs
sociaux du 115 dans les places
d'hébergement d'urgence le peu de
logements sociaux construit alors que la
demande ne cesse d'augmenter la coupe
des aPL votre loi va y ajouter de
l'affaiblissement considérable des
dispositifs de prévention des expulsions
elle constitue une attaque sans
précédent à l'encontre des droits et de
la protection des locataires et on sait
que un peu mal logement à coup humain
important dans l'accès à l'emploi à la
santé à la scolarité tout cela va peser
humainement et économiquement sur
l'ensemble de la société monsieur le
ministre du Logement c'est à vous que je
m'adresse désormais nous avons des
désaccords c'est certain mais je vous
sais par votre parcours sensible à la
question du mal logement et de vouloir
poursuivre le chemin insuffisant mais
nécessaire du logement d'abord cette loi
va pleinement à contre sens des
intentions de celui-ci c'est la
Fondation Abbé Pierre qui le dit j'ai
cru comprendre par voie de presse que
vous partagiez notre avis gagnons du
temps demandons au rapporteur de retirer
sa loi parce que nous savons vous et moi
qu'elle est dangereuse pour des millions
de nos concitoyens les personnes en
difficulté de logement mais aussi les
petits artisans les petits commerçants
sont les petites entreprises se trouvant
dans des locaux où ils sont sans droit
ni titre parce que ça aussi c'est une
réalité il existe une autre voie pour
améliorer les rapports locatifs celle
cons à sécuriser aussi bien le locataire
que le bailleur encadré à la baisse les
loyers revaloriser les APL mettre en
place une sécurité sociale du logement
ces dispositions et d'autres pourraient
faire l'objet d'une grande loi sur le
logement nous et nos collègues de la
nups sont disponibles pour vous faire de
nombreuses propositions dans un pays où
la crise du logement n'a jamais été
aussi importante depuis des décennies je
finirai monsieur le ministre chers
collègues par les mots de celui avec
lequel j'ai commencé l'abbé Pierre qui
je l'espère résonneront en vous autant
qu'il résonne en nous gouverner c'est
d'abord loger son peuple merci
merci monsieur pigman
alors je vous indique que sur la motion
sur la motion de Roger plage préalable
je suis saisie par le groupe la France
insoumise nue d'une demande de scrutin
public et j'annonce le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
avons passé aux explications bottes à ce
que messieurs les ministres
vous souhaitez
prendre la parole non monsieur
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
peut-être réagir en deux mots à ce
qu'ils viennent dire monsieur pickman
vous avez dit c'est un phénomène qui est
un épiphénomène
mais heureusement
heureusement qu'on a pas des squatteurs
toutes les minutes dans toutes les
maisons de France dans tous les
appartements de France heureusement
qu'on a pas des situations d'un pays
dans tous les rapports locatifs
heureusement que ce sont des cas qui
sont minoritaires sinon il y aurait
d'ailleurs plus de marchés locatifs
puisque personne n'oserait mettre en
location un bien immobilier si vous
savez que il y a une probabilité énorme
d'avoir un impayé mais pour autant même
si ce sont des situations qui sont
minoritaires et ce qu'on peut ne rien
faire et ce qu'on peut s'accommoder de
la situation actuelle et ce qu'on peut
laisser des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes dans des situations
déplorables parce qu'ils ont soit un
squatteur soit un occupant qui se
maintient pendant des années sans jamais
payer vous m'avez fait le reproche
monsieur bigmal de ne pas avoir
auditionné les squatteurs au cours de la
commission je le confirme je ne disne
pas des délinquants puisque le squat est
aujourd'hui un délit je ne vais pas
recevoir en commission des délinquants
en leur expliquant pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez squatté alors que le squat est
aujourd'hui pas juste dans ma
proposition de loi mais en général
aujourd'hui le squat est un délit et
c'est ça que vous n'arrivez faire
connaître vous avez cité énormément de
prénoms énormément d'histoires je tiens
à votre disposition les dizaines et
dizaines de témoignages que nous avons
reçus ceux de Cléa de Jean-Loup de
Bernadette d'Amélie de Nîmes de Robert
de Batman de Patricia de Doriana di
paulite de Tiffany de Jean-Philippe de
Anne de Hervé tous ceux qui nous ont
écrit et qui témoignent de leur
difficulté ce sont des témoignages
écrits je les mets à votre disposition
monsieur pickman discutons-en et donc
rejetons cette motion de rejet préalable
monsieur le garde des sceaux
[Applaudissements]
ce que ce que je note une fois encore
c'est que vous êtes dans l'idéologie la
plus
dogmatique qui soit je vais vous donner
un exemple l'article premier l'article
l'article premier bis pénalise les
marchands de sommeil vous nous faites 5
minutes sur les marchands de sommeil
vous n'avez pas lu le texte pardon vous
l'avez pas lu maintenant la grandeur
d'âme l'abbé Pierre qui devient votre
référence moi j'aimerais bien voir moi
si on venait investir votre domicile
vous voyez que vous rentriez chez vous
qu'avec votre clé vous ne puissiez plus
rentrer en vous entendrez
non non ça vaut pas pour les logements
sociaux mesdames la députée ça vaut pour
tout le reste
tu demandes et favorable merci Monsieur
gardesseau alors la parole est à Madame
sebahi pour le groupe et oui comme vous
le souhaitez
écologiste nul et pour 2 minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la première
bataille c'est de loger tout le monde
dignement je ne veux plus d'ici la fin
de l'année avoir des femmes et des
hommes dans les rues dans les bois ou
perdus c'est une question de dignité
c'est une question d'humanité et
d'efficacité je suis obligée de députer
mon propos avec cette citation
d'Emmanuel Macron dans cette proposition
de loi que nous avons à étudie
aujourd'hui va dans le mauvais sens
ignorez-vous les chiffres de la rue
ignorez-vous la hausse des loyers dans
les communes ont l'encadrement est
inexistant les squatteurs ne viennent
pas de nulle part c'est la raréfaction
du logement qui crée le squat et vous
proposez tout simplement de réinventer
la prison pour dette qui est pourtant
abolie en France depuis 1867
chers collègues de la majorité
sur un plan politique j'ai lu avec
quatre ans avec attention le rapport que
vous avez rendu j'ai relevé ce passage
dans lequel vous soulignez quoi
Parlement le nombre de textes déposés à
ce sujet au cours des années témoigne de
l'intérêt oui l'intérêt de la droite et
de l'extrême droite
un intérêt oui parce que comme vous il
déteste les pauvres et font de la
récupération politique sur ce thème
je voudrais ici rappeler c'est quelques
chiffres que vous avez manifestement
occulter au moment de rédiger votre
texte vous aimez ma rôder avec eux mais
savez-vous seulement que le 115 refait
refuse chaque soir un hébergement à plus
de 6000 personnes dont 1700 enfants
enfin il y a un chiffre sur lequel aucun
d'entre vous ne devrait fermer les yeux
celui des morts à la rue la rue a tué
623 personnes en 2021 623 personnes
meurt dans la rue mais vous souhaitez
les envoyer en prison plutôt qu'ils
puissent se loger comment voulez-vous
que les Français les plus démunis s'en
sortent quand vous les suites vous leur
supprimez même la possibilité de
réelonner leur dette
alors avec 3,1 million de logements qui
sont vacants votre peau proposition
passe totalement à côté d'un seul sujet
auquel nous devrions prioritairement
nous intéresser offrir de l'humanité au
lieu de faire de la politique de faits
divers si imaginaire
merci la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
peu
et pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres collègues nous allons
voter cette motion de rejet parce que je
pense que
comment
parce que je pense que c'est une loi qui
va dans une très mauvaise dans une très
mauvaise direction
moi aussi comme chacun ici sur ses bancs
je reçois dans ma permanence et des
propriétaires
qui subissent un squat
ou des impayés durables et je reçois
aussi beaucoup de locataires qui sont en
grande difficulté et avec l'inflation
que nous connaissons tout le monde
s'accorde à reconnaître qu'il y a une
explosion des quittances de loyer les
loyers mais aussi les charges qui
comprennent notamment les factures
d'énergie qui vont exploser et qui vont
rendre la possibilité pour des millions
de nos concitoyens d'avoir beaucoup de
difficultés à payer leur quittance de
loyer on le sait tous on le sait tous et
donc la seule question qui vaille c'est
est-ce que dans notre pays on est
capable de trouver un chemin pour
protéger les uns et les autres pour
protéger les propriétaires mais aussi
les locataires ou les personnes qui sont
en situation de mal logement or vous
utilisez un véhicule qui est une loi qui
est intitulée loin anti-squate qui est
une loi
on essaye de médiatiser des situations
qui sont gravissimes scandaleuses mais
exceptionnelle qui est celui de la
violation de domicile pour lequel tout
l'arsenal juridique existe pour
finalement durcir la législation pour
accélérer les expulsions locatives des
gens qui sont difficultés de paiement
c'est ça la réalité de cette loi c'est
pas la lutte contre les squats et donc
vous êtes un train de faire une loi
déséquilibrée qui va aller à l'encontre
des locataires et des et des personnes
en difficulté de logement pour protéger
des propriétaires pas les petits
propriétaires dont vous parlez mais
surtout les multipropriétaires qui font
une rente de l'immobilier de
l'augmentation des loyers
merci
la parole est à Monsieur needen pour le
groupe lot
si madame la Présidente je trouve
intéressante cette cette motion de rejet
et surtout le fait que le collègue de la
France insoumise ne manque pas d'aplomb
il y a deux heures de temps la main sur
le cœur il nous expliquait qu'il ne
pouvait pas avoir de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'il y a il y avait le
49-3 de la part du gouvernement et donc
que ça nous empêchait de pouvoir
discuter des textes deux heures après
sur une proposition de loi de notre
collègue kasbarian il nous propose une
motion de rejet pour justement qu'on ne
puisse pas discuter de ce texte c'est
quand même dommage
[Applaudissements]
quand quand on représente nos électeurs
quand on représente les Français quand
on est ici à l'Assemblée nationale il
faut avoir un minimum de cohérence et là
encore une fois vous prouver que vous
manquez totalement de cohérence ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans notre groupe nous
voulons avoir ce débat nous voulons
avoir ce débat car comme toute loi comme
toute proposition de loi elle est
améliorable nous avons déposé des
amendements pour tenter de l'améliorer
et c'est ce que nous ferons dans ces
débats nous voterons donc contre cette
motion de rejet préalable merci ma
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tanguy on le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre se rapporteur chers collègue
écoutez nous votre rencontre évidemment
cette motion de rejet préalable première
raison le texte de loi s'inspire très
largement d'une proposition qui avait
faite Marine Le Pen sur le mandat
précédent oui bah oui pour remettre pour
remettre la juste question pour remettre
la juste question de l'occupation
illégale des logements qui fait un tel
scandale auprès la population à guste
titre deuxième chose on ne supporte plus
deuxième chose oui enfin vous savez
collègue de la nupette ou votez très
généralement pour nous faire des leçons
de morale avec la majorité
présidentielle donc cessé de faire ses
agitations quand ça vous arrange alors
que le lendemain vous féliciter
d'attaque la majorité votre indignation
est un géométrie variable comme elle est
agiométrie variable sur le logement il
est insupportable de recevoir des leçons
morales de la nupes le PS le Parti
socialiste a largement contribué à
l'échelle de la politique du logement en
France depuis 40 ans vous êtes
co-responsable de ce que vous dénoncez
parfaitement correspondable les Verts
les écologistes sont co-responsables
madame Duflot a été ministre du Logement
voilà donc vous faites semblant de
découvrir des situations à laquelle vous
avez participé vous dirigez un nombre
incalculable de collectivités
territoriales un nombre incalculable de
communes y compris de grandes
collectivités urbaines qui ont beaucoup
de moyens pour le logement vous êtes
correspondables de la situation que vous
déplorez les communistes ont congéré au
Siècle gouvernement café aussi les
Monsieur Mélenchon quand il était
ministre de Monsieur Jospin dans la
gauche pluriel a-t-il démissionné en
protestation de la situation de la
politique du logement en France jamais
donc vos leçons de Morales sur la
situation de logement en France sont
insupportables et vous opposez les
données de viande qui payent votre
faillite sur le logement aux zones qui
ont investi dans un logement et qui sont
victimes du laxisme judiciaire donc il
n'y a que le rassemblement national qui
défend les données de gants sur les deux
bords ce victime du mal aux mains à
cause de vous et ce victime du laxisme
judiciaire dont les logements sont fait
donc nous voulons se débat nous allons
renforcer cette loi et tout ce qui
permet de défendre les petits
propriétaires nous le voterons merci la
parole est à Monsieur midi pour le
comprenez sans et avec mes excuses si
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues bon c'est une nouvelle fois
une motion de rejet déposée par la
France insoumise ça devient une habitude
et donc vous savez qu'elle n'a aucune
chance de passer et au final que ça va
uniquement nous faire perdre du temps et
que c'est sûrement une forme
d'obstruction continue et larvé mais
nous avons l'habitude depuis le début du
mandat
alors notre méthode à nous c'est celle
du débat c'est pour ça que nous sommes
tous réunis dans cette hémicycle et
c'est ce que nous ont demandé les
Françaises et les Français le travail et
les débats sur cette proposition de loi
sont bien engagées
depuis plusieurs semaines nous avons
examiné plusieurs centaines
d'amendements et nous avons eu de bons
débats en commission des débats
productifs utiles qui ont permis de
largement amender et modifier ce texte
et vous savez
vous savez cette proposition de loi elle
est très attendue par nos concitoyens
il suffit d'ouvrir le journal tous les
jours pour voir que nous citoyens
maintenant on écoute sincèrement on
écoute l'orateur on a écouté la motion
de Roger qui a été proposée donc vous
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
madame rogol
je vous invite à ce que nous puissions
avoir un débat le plus sera possible
même si les avis sont contraires donc on
écoute monsieur midi et lui seul s'il
vous plaît
c'est important parce que cette
proposition de loi elle est très
attendue par nos concitoyens il suffit
d'ouvrir le journal tous les jours pour
voir que nos concitoyens sont trop
nombreux à être victimes de squats et
d'arnaqueurs qui sont souvent
multirécidivistes et donc évidemment
nous proposons de continuer le travail
de ne pas éviter les débats et surtout
mes chers collègues de tout faire pour
que cette proposition de loi soit
adoptée merci
la parole est à Monsieur Martinet pour
la France insoumise nuque
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues essayons de prendre un petit
peu de hauteur puisque finalement le
débat sur cette proposition de loi c'est
un débat entre deux principes à valeur
constitutionnelle d'un côté le droit au
logement de l'autre le droit de
propriété si nous défendons cette notion
de rejet c'est parce que nous
considérons que cette proposition de loi
rond l'équilibre juridique entre ces
deux principes constitutionnels cette
proposition de loi est en défaveur du
droit au logement et donc de facto en
défaveur des locataires des mal logés et
des personnes sans abri je le dis avec
gravité si cette proposition de loi
s'applique dans le contexte de crise de
logement que nous vivons je rappelle que
dans le pays il y a 300 000 SDF 4
millions de personnes mal logées si
jamais cette proposition de loi
s'applique elle sera une véritable bombe
sociale une machine à fabriquer du
sans-abrisme voilà la réalité de cette
proposition je vais tenter de résumer
les deux principaux points de désaccord
que nous avons avec le texte
issu des travaux de la commission
premier point de désaccord ce texte
réduit les marges de manœuvre du juge
dans la procédure d'expulsion et là
attention quand on parle du juge dans la
procédure d'expulsion on ne parle pas
des squatteurs on parle de personnes qui
sont rentrées dans un logement toutes
les qualités qui ont eu un bail qui ont
payé leur loyer mais qui sont confrontés
à des difficultés financières comme ça
arrive à des millions de Français on
parle même de locataires qui paye leur
loyer rubis sur l'ongle mais qui de fait
d'un congé vente parce que leur
propriétaire veut vendre leur logement
les expulsent et bien dans cette
situation là vous réduisez le pouvoir
d'appréciation du juge vous réduisez la
durée des procédures d'expulsion et vous
empêcher le juge de faire son travail
c'est-à-dire de considérer la situation
sociale des familles pour éviter le
sans-abrisme et chers collègues moi je
suis très déçu des travaux en commission
parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle de savoir que au sein de la
priorité et y compris vis-à-vis du
gouvernement que finalement monsieur le
ministre du Logement il ne défend pas la
philosophie de ce texte on le sait mais
malheureusement cela n'a pas permis de
faire évoluer le texte je finis madame
la Présidente en disant qu'il y a eu une
coalition sur ce texte entre la minorité
présidentielle le RN et LR qui est le
député
la parole est à Madame Geneva pour les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur les ministres Michel
collègue monsieur pickman vous avez
explosé votre propos en militant et pas
en législateur un militant un militant
qui ne craint pas l'outrans vous avez
commencé votre propos en disant que
occuper un logement
squatter un logement c'est parfois pour
éviter la maladie et la mort comme si le
squat était un acte de légitime défense
deuxième exemple de trans lorsque vous
nous dites que
il s'agit par ce texte de protéger les
intérêts des spéculateurs des
multipropriétaires des escrocs je
reprends vos termes et des lobbies
immobiliers comme si
tout autre cas de figure n'existait pas
or les médias ne vous en déplaisent s'en
font régulièrement l'écho et vous ne
pouvez pas le nier troisième exemple
d'outrances lorsque vous dites que les
institutions ne font rien c'est comme si
depuis l'appel de l'abbé Pierre durant
l'hiver 1954 il ne s'était rien passé
dans notre pays si la question du
logement était demeurer le point aveugle
de toutes les politiques publiques vous
le savez bien que c'est absolument faux
et s'il ne vous fallait ne vous donner
qu'un exemple je citerai la loi DALO de
2007 excusé du peu alors je crois que je
crois que c'est toute trans je crois que
c'est toute trans dessert profondément
votre propos oui les difficultés de
logement existent c'est vrai c'est vrai
et nous avons le devoir d'y répondre et
non seulement les élus nationaux que
nous sommes mais les élus locaux les
mers ne font que cela essayez de
répondre aux besoins de leur population
en matière de logement et ça n'est pas
facile bref en aucun cas en aucun cas le
mal le logement ne peut légitimer le
squat c'est un raisonnement que nous ne
pouvons admettre et c'est la région pour
laquelle nous nous opposerons à cette
notion de rejet merci
la parole est au monsieur le président
Jean-Paul Mattei pour les démocrates
merci ma présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs des ministres je
crois qu'il faudrait qu'on s'intéresse
au texte qu'on est en train et j'espère
qu'on va discuter parce qu'il y a deux
aspects il y a l'aspect du squat et vous
l'avez même dit dans vos propos qui est
une une
mesure tout à fait
ad digne de de s'approprier un bien qui
vous appartient pas avec pour des petits
propriétaires et puis à l'aspect
contractuel des relations entre bailleur
et locataires et il me semble pour ça
que je suis un peu étonné de la remarque
de Stéphane peu il me semble que dans le
texte on essaie de maintenir ses
équilibres puisque on met le juge au
centre je dirais du débat sur cette
relation contractuelle qui est
nécessaire et qui est ancienne dans
notre législation et qui a toujours été
qui visait améliorer les rapports et
notamment pour le locataire et ça me
semble aller dans le bon sens il me
semble pas que le texte est en train de
rompre cet équilibre on on sait nous le
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
intéressé sur le fond du texte on s'est
posé également des questions sur cet
équilibre à respecter il y a bien deux
choses différentes entre le squat et
l'occupation dans le cas de contractuel
une relation entre un bailleur et un
locataire il me semble que le texte et
qui a évolué entre la Commission et
j'espère dans la discussion de cette
hémicycle a largement évolué d'autre
part je pense que on rend un service au
logement en sécurisant ces rapports
contractuels parce qu'à force de
fragiliser ces rapports on permet pas
aux investisseurs qui sont pas tous des
gros investisseurs de s'intéresser à la
pierre dans une démarche vertueuse parce
qu'on va laisser des portiers
d'immeubles non rénovés au centre dans
les centres-villes et la puissance
publique ne pourra pas tout faire alors
je pense ce texte est nécessaire il
n'est pas parfait on n'a pas résolu tous
les problèmes et bien évidemment il faut
qu'on débat de ce texte dans cette
hémicycle qu'on l'améliore et qu'ensuite
il soit je dirais vecteur de nouveaux
textes pour protéger et favoriser le
logement dans notre pays merci la parole
est à Monsieur Gérard le seul pour le
groupe socialiste et la parenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
ce texte tente ou plutôt prétexte de
répondre à quelques rares affaires de
squat qui ont été récemment médiatisés
et visent aussi les litiges de loyer des
impayés de locataires cette proposition
de loi amalgame squat de domicile squat
de bâtiment vide et locataire en impayés
elle représente en fait de graves recul
du droit au logement par un mélange de
genre dangereux entre le squat qui est
une occupation illicite on le sait d'un
logement après violation de propriété le
défaut de paiement d'un locataire qui se
trouve socialement en danger vous
assimilez un locataire en difficulté à
un squatteur ce n'est ni moralement ni
politiquement acceptable avec cette
proposition de loi il y a une vraie
remise en cause d'un corpus de règles
patiemment élaborée et qui vise à
protéger la partie réputée la plus
faible du contrat le locataire tripler
les peines de prison pour des cas de
squat apparenter un vol d'occupation
sans droit ni titre permettant de
prononcer des peines jusqu'à 10 ans de
prison tout en réduisant les délais de
maintien dans le domicile accordé par le
juge vulnérable attestent de votre
volonté strictement punitive pour
reprendre les mots du garde des sceaux
force doit rester à la loi il nous a
d'ailleurs donné des raisons
supplémentaires de voter la motion de
rejet en alertant sur plusieurs dérives
du texte et sur le très faible équilibre
entre la défense de la propriété et la
défense du locataire de son côté le
ministre du Logement renforcé des
alertes il faut trouver les moyens de
renforcer les logements d'urgence il
n'est pas possible de confondre mauvais
locataire et squatteur les locataires
notamment en situation de fragilité
doivent être accompagnées cette
proposition de loi est qualifiée de
honteuse par toutes les organisations
d'aide au logement à t'aider le Secours
Catholique que Samu social
ce sont des militants peut-être ce sont
des militants qui chaque jour sont au
plus près de ceux qui sont en difficulté
c'est eux que vous devez aussi entendre
cette inspiration finalement très
libérale et punitive de cette ppel ne
correspond ni à l'urgence sociale ni à
notre vision apaisée de la cohésion
sociale de notre pays nous voterons
cette potion de rejet merci la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal pour le
groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission des affaires
économiques j'ai écouté avec une grande
attention l'ensemble des orateurs sur
cette notion de rejet préalable et je
dois dire que le nouveau député que je
suis n'y voit que des raisons pour
suivre le débat et donc je ne comprends
pas qu'on fasse une motion de rejet
préalable alors même que les
intervenants qui visaient au rejet de
l'examen de ce texte nous ont donné des
arguments que nous a sur lesquels nous
allons échanger que nous allons
peut-être amender qui vont peut-être
faire bouger les lignes et c'est pour
cela que le groupe horizon à parenté
avec fierté votre rencontre cette motion
de rejet
alors je vais mettre au roi avec un
scrutin public la motion de rejet
préalable je vous invite à rejoindre vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 193 exprimés 193 majorités 97
pour 43 contre 150 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté
nous allons maintenant passer à la
discussion générale
avec comme premier orateur monsieur
Aurélien Tachet pour le groupe
écologiste et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue puisque cette
motion de rejet n'a finalement pas été
adoptée je le regrette on va parler un
petit peu du fond de votre texte
vous attaquer monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être avez-vous été vexé de retirer
l'article le plus brutal de votre
proposition de loi l'article 3 qui
visait à créer une sanction pénale pour
les personnes qui resteraient dans leur
logement quand une procédure d'expulsion
est enclenchée alors même qu'il n'en
nulle part où aller mais vous saviez que
vous pouviez compter sur les députés des
républicains du rassemblement national
pour y ajouter une dose encore plus
forte d'inhumanité c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'ils ont fait en commission avec
l'ajout de deux nouveaux articles
nauséabonds là souhaitant que
l'occupation Sandra ni titre d'un
immeuble libère son propriétaire de
l'obligation d'entretien du bien
véritable Blanchin de Néo marchand de
sommeil cette définition englobra en
effet désormais la famille qui alors que
des moisissures empêchent les enfants de
respirer que le balcon le plafond menace
de s'effondrer arrêter de payer le loyer
votre texte toujours en partant de cette
définition du vol pourraient aussi
conduire à ce que l'occupant Sandrine
titre d'un entrepôt ou d'un entrepôt
chers collègues ou une mère sans abri et
son bébé souffrant du froid pourraient
se réfugier soit lui puni de 7 ans de
prison une sanction finalement plus
lourde que pour un délit d'initié ou un
conflit d'intérêt CQFD enfin vous
proposez que cette peine puisque je le
rappelle l'article 1 se base bien sur le
vol soit étendu à 15 années de réclusion
quand l'occupation est commise en bande
organisée les militants du droit au
logement présent ce soir à côté de
l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes donc
pas traités comme des voleurs c'est vrai
ils seront été comme des assassins 15
ans de prison avec ce texte chers
collègues la mafia du mal logement a de
beaux jours devant elle mais c'en est
fini des défenseurs du mal logé
et puis vous ne vous arrêtez pas là
puisque votre texte diminue aussi les
délais pendant lesquels les locataires
en difficulté peuvent régulariser leur
loyer que vous retirez au juge la
faculté de ne pas résilier un bail
contre un accord quand un accord entre
propriétaire et locataire est trouvé ou
qu'il peut attester de la bonne foi du
locataire et que vous empêchez aussi les
travailleurs sociaux qui souffrent déjà
tant de faire leur métier monsieur
casbariian même si les seuls sans abris
que vous connaissez sont certainement
ceux qui vous arrivent parfois
d'enjamber je voudrais ici vous rappeler
quelques chiffres fin août 2022 42 000
enfants vivaient dans les hébergements
d'urgence des abris de fortune ou dans
la rue selon les données de l'UNICEF et
de la Fédération des acteurs de la
solidarité 4 millions de Français sont
non ou mal logés selon la Fondation Abbé
Pierre votre proposition de loi en
réalité ne fait que mettre sous le tapis
les vrais enjeux du logement aujourd'hui
vous prétendez sécuriser les rapports
entre propriétaires bailleurs et
locataires mais vous ne vous attaquez
jamais aux problèmes à la racine pour
nous écologistes il est par exemple
urgent de s'attaquer au sujet de la
garantie universelle des loyers afin de
rassurer les propriétaires et de
permettre au moins bien d'entre nous qui
n'ont pas de riches garant pour les
protéger de se loger des impératifs
aussi d'encadrer ses loyers qui seront
ainsi moins dur à payer et d'en finir
avec les rentes et la spéculation
immobilière qu'Emmanuel Macron en son
temps avait lui-même dénoncé je voudrais
conclure en disant que votre loi est une
terrible régression sociale et
démocratique qui va conduire à
l'explosion du nombre de 100 abris à
moins que vous ayez aussi prévu de
réintroduire le délit de vagabondage
pour envoyer toutes les personnes sur
domicile fixe en prison bref toujours à
court d'idées pour éradiquer la pauvreté
vous en déborder pour la criminaliser et
c'est pourquoi les oppositions les
autres Logistics s'opposeront de toute
nos forces pardon à votre loi je vous
remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane peu pour le groupe des
gauches démocratique nu et pour 5
minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
je l'ai dit cette loi pour nous va dans
une mauvaise direction notre pays
traverse une crise terrible 4 millions
sont de personnes sont sans domicile ou
mal logés et vous choisissez ce moment
pour partir en croisade contre les
squatteurs mais en réalité
mais en réalité c'est pas les squatteurs
en réalité ce sont surtout contre les
locataires en difficulté cette
proposition de loi ne répond rien au
fond du problème comment faire
pour que la fragilisation de celle et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas faire ou plus
faire face aux charges du logement
n’entraînent pas les petits
propriétaires dans cette spirale du
déclassement si l'intention des
rapporteurs avait été de traiter cette
question comment les uns n'entraînent
pas les autres sans doute aurait-il été
dû remettre sur la table le projet
avorté de la garantie universelle des
loyers d'une part où aurait-il d'autre
part proposé de revaloriser des aPL
insuffisantes mais soignées protéger
n'est pas le sujet ici cette proposition
de loi est d'abord une loi d'affichage
qui vise à monter en épargne des faits
isolés et largement médiatisée pour
verser dans un populisme inquiétant sous
les applaudissements de l'extrême droite
bien sûr et d'une droite qui ne sait
plus où elle habite
je ne suis malheureusement pas surpris
de ce choix car au fond elle s'inscrit
dans la continuité des politiques
conduites ces cinq dernières années en
matière de logement en effet alors que
le logement est un droit à valeur
constitutionnelle
n'avait
eu de 16 de faire d'en faire une
marchandise vous avez fait du logement
social le parent pauvre des politiques
publiques et mis à genoux les offices
HLM Vous avez réformé les aides au
logement et économiser plus d'un
milliard et demi d'euros par an sur le
dos des allocataires que votre
proposition de loi puisse générer plus
de détresse plus de chaos et
accessoirement engorger un peu plus des
tribunaux saturés sans régler aucun
problème vous n'en avez qu'une au lieu
de les traiter vous criminalisez le mal
logement vous nous invitez ainsi dès
l'article 2 à élargir la procédure
d'expulsion extrajudiciaire de l'article
38 de la loi DALO en créant une
dangereuse confusion entre la violation
de domicile qui est une atteinte à la
vie privée inacceptable et l'occupation
son droit mythique d'un logement vacant
Vous banalisez ainsi une procédure
exceptionnelle qui doit pourtant
impérativement le rester tant elle est
attente à toi au droit de la défense et
au droit d'être par un juge vous avez
vous envisagez également à l'article 3
la création d'un nouveau délit visant
des locataires en impayés de loyer de me
rendre dans un logement malgré une
décision de justice leur demandant de le
quitter vous proposiez ainsi de faire
des locataires qui ne peuvent plus payer
leur loyer des délinquants vous
continuez dans la même lancée à
l'article 4 en supprimant la possibilité
pour le juge d'accorder d'office des
délais de paiement locataire ce qui
était l'un des acquis de la loi de lutte
contre l'exclusion dit loi Aubry de 1998
et cerise sur le gâteau vous nous
proposez enfin l'article 5 de réduire
les délais de procédure contentieuse du
traitement des impayés de loyer votre
texte et ainsi d'un bout à l'autre un
texte inutile et dangereux qui loin de
pacifier et de sécuriser les relations
entre propriétaires et locataires va les
empoisonner un peu plus à l'inverse si
vous aviez voulu essayer de réconcilier
les Français au lieu de les diviser les
propriétaires comme les locataires vous
auriez pu prendre le chemin et vous
mettre dans les pas par exemple de
Jean-Louis Borloo qui en 2005 a créé les
protocoles Borlo et aujourd'hui dans
toutes les sous-préfectures de France il
se signe tous les jours des protocoles
10 protocoles Barlow Borno qui permet à
des locataires qui sont en impayés du
loyer de garder le APL moyennant un
échelonnement de paiement ça n'existe
que le port le logement HLM ça pourrait
être étendu au secteur privé voilà une
loi de réconciliation entre le bailleur
et le locataire plutôt que de les
diviser vous auriez pu aussi réfléchir à
la loi de 2014 la loi alur avec sa
garantie universelle des loyers un
décret d'application qui n'a jamais été
pris par le Premier ministre de l'époque
Manuel Valls alors qu'elle devait
rentrer en vigueur au 1er janvier 2016
avec cette garantie universelle des
loyers il y avait là un chemin pour
protéger le propriétaire lui écrire son
loyer le sécuriser dans son acte de
propriétaire bailleur et de garantir au
locataire la possibilité de faire face
et éventuellement à des impayés ou à des
difficultés passagères avec des
étalement de paiement il y a des chemins
empruntés pour réconcilier les Français
il y a des chemins empruntés pour
réconcilier le droit au logement avec le
droit de la propriété vous avez choisi
de défendre uniquement le droit de la
propriété et d'affaiblir le droit au
logement Vous faites une grave erreur
c'est une très mauvaise direction merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Le Normand
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire et pour 5
minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
régulièrement des faits divers faisant
état de logement squatté ponctu
l'actualité nous avons tous entendu les
histoires de petits propriétaires ayant
acheté un appartement une maison pour
s'assurer d'un complément de
rémunération et qui malheureusement ne
le touche pas finalement car leur
propriété a été squattée ce phénomène
est une réalité partout en France mais
il a une acuité particulière notamment
dans les territoires d'outre-mer à
Mayotte en Guadeloupe par exemple trop
nombreux sont ceux qui voient leurs
terrains occupés aussi pour notre groupe
on ne peut se satisfaire qu'il existe
toujours des cas où le droit de la
propriété qui est un droit fondamental
absolu soit bafoué et en tant que
législasseur législateur pardon nous
devons trouver des solutions pour ceux
qui se voient des possédés
gardons quand même à l'esprit que ces
situations aussi pénibles soient-elles
sans minoritaires en 2021 seul 170
propriétés en solitaire sollicitait
l'intervention de la préfecture contre
des squats souvenez-vous ont également
qu'il y a un lien de causalité entre les
tensions sur le marché de logement et la
multiplication des squats là aussi les
chiffres le démontrent enfin rappelons
que les mesures prises en matière de
lutte contre l'occupation illégale ne
sont que des palliatifs elle ne
suffiront pas à régler la problématique
du mal logement car elles interviennent
à posteriori une fois le logement occupé
ceci étant dit ce n'est pas aux petits
propriétaires d'endosser les
conséquences de la crise du logement et
certains squatteurs continuent
d’ailleurs de jouer avec les failles de
la loi pour se maintenir illégalement
dans des logements qui ne leur
appartiennent pas pour ces cas-là nous
considérons qu'il est nécessaire d'agir
la loi hasard avait proposé de corriger
quelques écueils concernant la procédure
d'évacuation accélérée de logement par
décision administratives cette
proposition de loi vient combler
certaines lacunes elle précise qu'un
logement même vide de meubles peut-être
considéré comme un domicile elle opère
également une dissociation entre
l'introduction par voie de fait et le
maintien dans les lieux par voie de fées
de même le renforcement des sanctions à
l'égard des squatteurs va dans le bon
sens venons-en maintenant aux
dispositions relatives au rapport
locatifs rappelons que l'immense
majorité des Français des ménages
français même dans les périodes
difficiles priorise l'acquittement de
leur loyer
ce dont truc qui ne cesse qui cesse de
payer non souvent aucun autre choix et
ces situations jusqu'à là exceptionnelle
risque malheureusement de se banaliser
on en a parlé l'inflation qui se
répercute sur le coup de l'énergie des
loyers rond aujourd'hui difficilement
soutenable et fin de mois pour bon
nombre de Français et ce sera une
surprise pour personne le risque
d'impayé des charges des loyers va
augmenter aussi nous sommes favorables à
la transmission systématique par
l'huissier de justice du campement de
pays à la CAPEX afin de privilégier la
prise en charge la plus en aval possible
des difficultés du locataire c'est un
premier pas nécessaire pour accompagner
ceux qui sont en difficulté mais notre
droit est aussi par essence plus
protecteur de l'intérêt de la partie
réputée la plus faible locataire au
risque parfois d'oublier l'intérêt du
propriétaire aussi nous sommes
favorables à la réduction des délais
dans les procédures contentieuses du
traitement des impayés de loyer d'autant
que la réécriture en commission a permis
de rétablir une forme d'É suivre avec la
possibilité les co locataires de
réclamer au juge des délais
supplémentaires lorsque son relogement
ne peut se faire
reste le principal problème le manque de
logement disponible et abordable qui ne
fait toujours pas l'objet d'une
politique ambitieuse un exemple
difficile chronique de construction de
logements sociaux alors que 125 000
logements sociaux devaient être
construits par an ce sont finalement en
2021 sont 4000 qui ont été agréés et le
chiffre devrait de nouveau être en
baisse en 2022 selon l'Union sociale
pour l'habitat je ne veux pas faire ici
le procès du quinquennat précédent mais
il faut reconnaître que certaines
décisions qui ont été prises ont été
défavorables au bailleur comme la baisse
du montant des APL ou le RLS
en termes c'est leur capacité à inverse
à investir qui sont ressent aujourd'hui
et donc avec un parc déficitaire nous
risquons pourtant d'alimenter le
phénomène que nous entendons aujourd'hui
endiguer c'est-à-dire l'occupation
illégale des logements vous l'avez
compris les examens des amendements qui
suivront est important pour ce texte qui
devrait recueillir un avis favorable du
groupe que je représente avec une
exigence préserver l'équilibre entre le
droit de propriété et le droit au
logement je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Paul midi pour
le groupe Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues cette proposition de loi elle
vise à lutter contre les squats et
contre les contentieux locatifs l'ont et
abusif pour améliorer la protection des
petits propriétaires des petits
bailleurs mais aussi de locataires qui
peuvent se faire abuser par de faux
propriétaires
alors je salue le travail du rapporteur
Guillaume kasbariian qui nous a permis
de mener de nombreuses auditions qui
étaient assez édifiantes et je crois que
c'est important que nous arrontions sur
quelques exemples très concrets
je vais vous parler d'abord de Mégane
qui a 24 ans j'aimerais vous dire
qu'elle habite dans la Somme mais depuis
le décès de sa maman elle n'a plus de
logement son seul logement était la
maison de sa maman dont elle a hérité et
sa seule ressource locataire qu'elle
était
les loyers qu'elle était censée
percevoir mais le locataire ne paie plus
depuis un an et demi elle n'a plus le
logement elle n'a plus de ressource et
elle nous dit quelque chose de très
clair c'est moi qui suis dehors et c'est
lui qui est au chaud
Cécilia qui a un appartement 35 mètres
carrés en Île-de-France ces locataires
ne paient plus depuis le second mois ça
fait 6 ans qu'ils sont dans
l'appartement pour Cécilia c'est 75000
euros d'un pays c'est 25000 euros de
charges qu'elle a dû continuer à payer
et c'est 8000 euros de frais d'avocat
c'est s'il a dû changer de logement pour
pouvoir payer toutes ces charges et elle
va devoir vendre cet appartement avec
évidemment une forte décote puisqu'il
est squatté je pourrais aussi vous
parler du propriétaire qui fait face à
un squatteur qu'il a traîné en justice
pour défaut de garde de corps de fenêtre
ce squatteur a fait une chute et il a
demandé une indemnisation aux
propriétaires qu'il squattent pour
défaut l'entretien en l'état de notre
droit
la justice a condamné ce propriétaire à
60000 euros de dédommagement à son
squatteur ou encore pour illustrer la
diversité de ses drames le 4 cette
personne dans les Côtes d'Or qui rendent
chez elle et trouve une famille
installée elle-même dupée par un faux
propriétaire qui encaisse de l'argent
alors nous avons écouté toutes ces
personnes et ils ont tous dit la même
chose qu'ils avaient perdu la confiance
dans la justice de leur pays
et donc cette proposition de loi ça
n'est pas une proposition de loi contre
les petits locataires en galère
passagère ça peut arriver à tout le
monde
ça n'est pas une loi contre ceux qui de
bonne foi ont un moment de difficulté ça
n'est pas une loi pour donner des moyens
à de riches propriétaires de maltraiter
des locataires pauvres
il ne s'agit pas d'enlever des
protections pour les locataires comme
par exemple à très hivernale qui bien
sûr et maintenu dans ce texte mais à
l'inverse il ne faut pas que nous nous
trompions de sujet cette proposition de
loi elle est là pour combattre des
personnes qui sont foncièrement
malhonnêtes
pour combattre des arnaqueurs patentés
pour combattre des personnes qui abusent
en conscience des failles de notre droit
pour combattre des arnaqueurs qui
souvent sont multiples récidivistes
alors à ceux qui dans cette émission
défendront le squat et les squatteurs
comme nous l'avons vu dans le travail en
commission je rappellerai l'article 17
de la Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme
et du Citoyen la propriété est un droit
inviolable et sacré nul ne peut en être
privé cette proposition de loi c'est une
proposition juste équilibrée j'espère
donc que nous aurons un bon débat comme
au commissions sur de bonnes bases avec
l'objectif de redonner conscience
confiance pardon en la justice à Mégane
à Cecilia et à toutes les victimes
d'abus et d'escroquerie et surtout mes
chers collègues d'éviter de les jeter
dans les bras de l'extrême droite merci
la parole est à Madame Géraldine
Grangier pour le rassemblement national
et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues cela fait longtemps que
le groupe rassemblement national défend
le sujet qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
nous sommes heureux qu'il arrive enfin
dans cette hémicycle et je me permets à
cette occasion de relire les mots de
notre proposition de loi datant déjà de
mars 2021 les atteintes au droit de
propriété qui font régulièrement la une
de l'actualité depuis des années
souligne que les textes en vigueur sont
clairement insuffisants pour défendre ce
droit fondamental
rappelons que fut un temps où la notion
même de propriété figurait dans la
devise de la République française la
propriété qui est un principe
intrinsèque reste inséparable des autres
libertés humaines
depuis plusieurs années et
singulièrement depuis le fameux droit au
logement opposable le droit de propriété
est remis en cause et les propriétaires
sont bien souvent démunis devant des
squats qui sont en réalité purement et
simplement des vols
la procédure reste lourde et privilégie
toujours le délinquant plutôt que le
propriétaire
un squatteur est un occupant qui ne
possède ni droit ni titre sur le bien
qu'il occupe il s'agit d'un individu qui
est entré dans un bien par effraction
sans autorisation
l'article
226-4 du code pénal définit la notion de
squat comme une introduction dans le
domicile d'autrui à l'aide de manœuvres
menaces voie de fée ou contrainte
beaucoup de nos concitoyens conservent
un sentiment concret face à ça parce
qu'il existe un déséquilibre entre la
rapidité avec laquelle un squatteur peut
élire domicile dans un logement sans y
être autorisé et la longueur de la
procédure légale que les propriétaires
qui jouissent pourtant de leurs droits
de propriété doivent respecter pour les
déloger
il arrive même dans certains cas que les
préfectures refusent de procéder à
l'expulsion de squatteurs cela renforce
à juste titre la pression d'injustice
d'inefficacité et d'impunité de ces
personnes qui elles continuent à se
sentir toute puissant
car en aucun cas les propriétaires de
logements squattés ne doivent intervenir
directement s'ils le font ils s'exposent
à une peine d'emprisonnement et au
paiement d'amande qu'ils seront forcés
eux de s'akiter de plus il est difficile
de donner un délai moyen d'expulsion
puisque celui-ci varie d'un tribunal à
l'autre c'est le juge des contentieux
qui est compétent pour trancher les
litiges civiles sur les baux
d'habitation mais plus le tribunal
saisit aura d'affaires à traiter plus
les délaisseront longs il faut ainsi
compter plusieurs semaines à plusieurs
années si la responsabilité de l'État
est engagée
64% des propriétaires bailleurs ne
détiennent qu'un seul logement en
location et un tiers d'entre eux sont
des retraités les revenus qu'ils tirent
de leur bien en location sont absolument
indispensables pour leur garantir une
retraite sereine
et ces derniers n'ont pas contrairement
au gros bailleur les moyens de faire
gérer leurs biens par des tiers ou de
les faire protéger par des entreprises
de surveillance ils se retrouvent donc
dans une situation catastrophique
lorsqu'ils sont victimes d'impayés ou
pire encore de squatteurs qu'ils ne
peuvent déloger c'est la raison pour
laquelle les squats qui constituent à la
fois une violation de la sphère intime
et une privation de l'usage de la
propriété son ressenti si fortement par
tous comme une injustice criante après
les évolutions de la loi ASAP en 2020
qui ont déjà accéléré les procédures ce
texte vient encore conforter des
nouvelles possibilités à la main des
propriétaires
la présente proposition de loi clarifie
en effet la définition juridique du
squat et sanctionne enfin mieux cette
infraction elle accélère les procédures
dans les litiges locatives rend
opératoire la possibilité de résilier le
bail pour manquement aux obligations
contractuelles du locataire et pénalise
le fait de rester dans le logement en
dépit des décisions de justice
défavorable elle va également un peu
plus loin dans la sanction des
squatteurs nous sommes globalement en
faveur de ces mesures de bon sens mais
il aura fallu trop de temps pour arriver
à ce texte et trop d'histoires
dramatiques qui ont fait l'actualité ces
dernières années merci merci Madame la
député
la parole est à Madame Daniel Simonet
pour la France insoumise nuque et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le rapporteur casse
variant votre loi c'est une véritable
fabrique à son domicile fixe n'avez-vous
pas honte face à la crise du logement à
la crise sociale qui s'accentue de jour
en jour vous n'avez rien trouvé de mieux
faciliter les expéditions locatives pour
impayer de loyer criminaliser plus
encore les occupants sont de vernis
titre que celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien de quoi il
s'agit en aucun cas cette loi ne
s'occupe des résidences principales et
secondaires qui pourraient se retrouver
squatter la loi prévoit déjà ces cas-là
l'Observatoire des squats n'a dénombré
que 170 cas de squats de domicile en
2021 et la majorité des cas ont été
résolus passés à trois ans de prison ne
changera rien non cette loi permet
d'abord d'expulser très rapidement des
locataires pour un pays de loyer en
mettant fin notamment à l'autonomie du
juge et tous les locataires du pack
privé comme social sont concernés
jusqu'à présent il y avait deux mois
entre l'assignation et l'audience ce qui
laissait tout juste le temps d'élaborer
un rapport social sur la situation du
locataire avec la réduction des délais
le juge n'aura plus accès à ce rapport
social il ne pourra plus suspendre la
résiliation du bail afin de tenir compte
de la situation du locataire en a payé
de loyer et ne pourra plus proposer le
maintien dans les lieux pendant la durée
de l'étalement de sa dette dorénavant
dès lors qu'une procédure en justice
sera engagée pour impayée de loyer la
clause de résiliation du bail pourra
être immédiate certes le locataire
pourra demander la suspension de cette
réalisation du bail mais plus de 60% des
locataires ne sont pas défendus à
l'heure actuelle alors comment
voulez-vous qu'il soit capable d'engager
cette démarche quelle ligne humanité
avez-vous conscience que des accidents
de la vie qui font que nombre de
locataires peuvent se retrouver en
impayés de loyer votre employeur par
exemple étant liquidation judiciaire il
faut compter au moins trois mois avant
d'accéder à la garantie de salaire vous
pouvez donc vous retrouver en impayés de
trois mois de loyer dehors expulsion
votre couple explose quelques mois de
retard de loyer dehors expulsion la CAF
accumule ses retards à votre rencontre
dehors expulsion vous arrivez à la
retraite mais il y a des tas de galère
dans votre dossier avant de toucher
votre pension dehors et expulsion une
épidémie tient un bloc le pays confiné
vous ne pouvez pas travailler et le
gouvernement met des mois avant de vous
accorder dehors des aides dehors et
expulsion
4,1 millions chers collègues 4,1 million
de personnes mal logées
2,4 millions de demandeurs 42 000
enfants en domicile en France des loyers
trop chers une explosion des impayés de
loyer mais vous votre priorité c'est
expulser
pire vous aviez même prévu que si le
locataire subissait la résiliation de
son contrat mais restez dans les lieux
il deviendrait locataire sans droit ni
titre donc en situation d'occupation
listique et il risquait trois ans de
prison et 45000 euros d'amende cette loi
est une fabrique à sans-abri quand
Monsieur Emmanuel Macron promettait en
2017 il n'y ait plus une personne à la
rue sa solution c'était donc celle-là
mettre les locataires en impayés de
loyer les sans-abris en prison j'ai
assisté aux auditions préalables
d'avocat spécialistes des occupations
illicites et de l'umpi tous des
approuvent de mettre dans une même loi à
la question des occupations licites et
des impayés de loyer tous ont trouvé
excessif oui excessif d'empêcher le juge
de surseoir à la résiliation du bail et
tous reconnaissent que le triplement de
la peine de prison n'aura aucun impact
les fragiles dispositifs de prévention
des dettes et des expulsions locatives
Vous les balayez avec cette loi vous
prétendez défendre des petits
propriétaires aux grande retraite trop
faible mais alors augmenter ses pensions
de retraite au lieu d'allonger l'âge de
départ de la retraite à 65 ans parce que
figurez-vous que les locataires en
difficulté de payer leur loyer eux aussi
pour les retraités ont des trop faibles
pensions de retraite alors arrêtez votre
hypocrisie plus de 70% des logements
location sont détenus par des gros
bailleurs gros bailleurs privés et gros
bailleurs sociaux et votre loi c'est du
sur mesure pour la FN pour la fnaïm qui
d'ailleurs ne cesse de la défendre dans
nombre de médias et pour eux vous
inventer une nouvelle définition du
terme domicile un immeuble entier laissé
vacants par un professionnel de
l'immobilier spécialisé dans la
spéculation dorénavant il s'agira de
domicile c'est le jugement vide son
squatter alors que la priorité devrait
être de les réquisitionner c'en est au
point que le garde des sceaux lui-même a
critiqué cette invention du domicile son
meuble le logement pour vous
d'abord et avant tout un produit
financier sur l’état du banquier et ce
placement doit rapporter il vous faut
défendre la rente coûte que coûte le
logement pour nous c'est un droit
essentiel le droit au logement doit
l'emporter sur le droit de spéculer sur
le logement et c'est un bien extraire
extraire du marché de sa
financiarisation alors il y a bien
d'autres mesures à prendre pour résoudre
la crise de logement et non de fabriquer
des SDF à mettre en prison merci
la parole est à Madame Annie Genval pour
les républicains et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
l'actualité est régulièrement émaillée
de fait de squats privance
scandaleusement des propriétaires
souvent medestes de l'accès à leur
logement sans que la puissance publique
ne parvienne toujours dans des délais
acceptables d'évacer ces délinquants et
quand ils y parviennent c'est
généralement pour découvrir un logement
dégradé par pur rétorsion que les médias
sont fassent les côtes traduits en fait
c'est impuissance à empêcher le
phénomène il est intéressant de noter
que cette situation qui n'est pas propre
à la France peut prendre dans certains
pays des proportions inquiétantes qui
doivent nous inciter à la juguler ainsi
en Espagne les squats ont-ils augmenté
de 40% en 5 ans
mais la réalité quel que soit les payer
toujours la même choc émotionnel frais
d'avocat réparation importante délais
insupportables en 2019 notre collègue
Julien Aubert dépose une proposition de
loi avec une augmentation du quantum de
la peine porté à 3 ans de prison et
45000 euros d'amende un pouvoir accru
des pouvoirs publics pour évincer les
squatteurs dans des délais rapides une
qualification du délit ces propositions
présentées au moment de l'examen de la
loi à Jacques ont presque tout été
retoqués par la majorité il est heureux
qu'elle est évolué depuis
le 20 septembre dernier je présente une
PPL pour traiter ce problème non résolu
dont l'examen devait intervenir le 1er
décembre jour de la niche des
républicains la majorité décide de
prendre la même initiative le 18 octobre
dernier dont l'examen intervient
opportunément avant le jour de notre
niche me prenant ainsi de vitesse
j'aurais pu en concevoir de l'humeur et
prendre le risque de voir abandonner des
mesures qui ne se trouvaient pas dans
votre PPL monsieur le rapporteur qui
reprend notamment l'augmentation du
quantum de la peine que nous
préconisions j'ai jugé plus utile de me
rapprocher de vous et de voir dans
quelle mesure nous pouvions travailler
ensemble travailler ensemble
avec le rapporteur et je la remercie
nous avons pu nous mettre d'accord sur
un point à mes yeux essentiels à savoir
la qualification du squat le squat
s'apparente au vol conformément à
l'article
311-1 du code pénal je le cite le vol et
la soustraction frauduleuse de la chose
d'autrui du reste les peines sont
identiques revenir sur cette
dispositions adoptées en commission avec
un avis favorable du rapporteur serait
un très mauvais signal j'en ai toutefois
revu la formulation par un amendement
pour des questions légistiques et aussi
pour distinguer le quantum de peine d'un
squatteur de celui d'un locataire
mauvais payeur
si nous en restons là il faut bien
reconnaître que certaines situations ne
sont pas couvertes par le droit par la
loi et ses regrettables ainsi en est-il
des locaux à usage économique bureau ou
commerce qui connaissent eux aussi
régulièrement des phénomènes de squat
ces suivrai qu'un véritable marché est
né avec des sociétés dont l'objet est
d'organiser l'occupation de locaux vides
par des locataires modestes étudiants
apprentis jeunes travailleurs
fonctionnaires j'ai résidence temporaire
tiennent les squatteurs à distance tout
en offrant des logements à des prix
imbattables c'est le sens d'un
amendement que je présenterai visant à
élargir ou locaux à caractère commercial
économique la peine prévue par cette
proposition de loi un autre point me
préoccupe
si cette proposition de loi est adoptée
la même peine touchera désormais le
squatteur et le propriétaire qui agit
pour récupérer son bien songeons chers
collègues que dans le droit actuel et le
garde des sceaux le disait tout à
l'heure la victime en cours une peine
plus lourde que le squatteur une
aberration totale
mettre sur un même plan la victime et le
squatteur pose en soi un problème que
tout Français doté de bon sens ne peut
comprendre un des principes de notre
droit et la proportionnalité de la peine
imaginons le cas de figure suivante
un propriétaire effrayé par la lenteur
des procédures et les coûts d'avocat
décident de payer le squatteur pour
qu'il s'en aille c'est une manœuvre si
un propriétaire change la serrure de son
bien pour empêcher le squatteur d'y
revenir c'est une manœuvre dans ces cas
il risque trois ans de prison et 45000
euros d'amende comme celui qui se sera
introduit dans son domicile ce n'est ni
compréhensible ni admissible c'est
pourquoi je présente à l'amendement
visant à établir une peine raisonnable
et proportionnée pour les propriétaires
qui parfois désespérés tente
pacifiquement sans violence mi menace ni
voix de fait de rentrer dans leur bon
droit le squat ne serait être la réponse
au même logement qui est une réalité que
nul ne ni mais qui n'autorise pas à
violer la loi la propriété étant un
droit inviolable et sacré j'invite la
majorité le gouvernement à ne pas se
montrer frileux merci à prendre
courageusement le problème à bras le
corps si tous ceux qui ont des
difficultés
problèmes une légitimité à squatter on
voit bien à quel désordre cela conduirai
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à monsieur Martineau pour le
groupe les démocrates et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues la propriété privée est un des
principes fondamentaux de notre
Constitution inscrite dans notre
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 nous devons agir lorsque
celle-ci est remise en cause
les affaires récurrentes d'occupation
illicites de logement peu nombreuses
existent réellement ainsi la loi doit
évoluer lorsque cela est possible et
utile le squat est d'ores et déjà puni
par notre droit une procédure
d'accélérer d'expulsion des squatteurs a
été créé en 2007 mais des fragilités
subsistent par ailleurs et même si cela
n'a rien à voir il existe également des
situations qui ponctuent l'actualité et
qui relèvent des relations entre un
bailleur et un locataire c'est pourquoi
le groupe démocrate salut la démarche et
la volonté du rapporteur de venir à bout
de ses affaires qui quelquefois mettent
dans des situations très délicates les
propriétaires
à titre d'exemple nous considérons que
la caractérisation légale du squat
proposé par ce texte va dans le bon sens
ainsi que l'augmentation des sanctions
contre les marchands de sommeil que nous
avons voté en commission
au groupe démocrate nous souhaitons
cependant prendre toutes les situations
en compte parce que à côté de situations
abusives existent des situations où les
locataires sont en grande difficulté
dans ces cas-là les pouvoirs publics
doivent être là pour aider et prendre le
relais
ainsi au cours de nos débats sur ce
texte nous tâcherons de nous appliquer
cette méthode qui vise à bien distinguer
toutes les situations et appelons de nos
vœux à ce qu'elle soit partagée par
l'ensemble de nos collègues tout d'abord
veillez à ce que les dispositions votées
soient applicables efficaces et cible
l'objectif poursuivi puis préserver
l'équilibre entre les droits des
propriétaires et ceux des locataires en
respectant le droit des contrats car oui
sécuriser les rapports locatifs est
essentiels aussi bien pour l'un que pour
l'autre à cet égard nous veillerons à ce
que le texte permettent d'établir une
différence entre le locataire de bonne
foi et celui qui ne l'est pas
il n'est pas question ici de faire
exploser le nombre de contentieux et
d'expulsions de locataires de bonne foi
qui se retrouverait en difficulté de
manière temporaire c'est pour cela que
nous considérons essentiels de préserver
la capacité du juge à intervenir en
analysant chaque situation nous
porterons ainsi un amendement qui vise à
conserver le pouvoir d'appréciation du
juge et ainsi faire jouer ou non la
clause résolutoire
notons à cet égard que nos échanges en
commission ont permis de souligner que
la majorité des locataires en situation
d'impayés locatif ne connaissez pas
leurs droits et qu'il n'était pas donc
en mesure de les faire valoir notamment
auprès du juge
c'est pourquoi nous jugeons nécessaires
de ne pas supprimer le pouvoir d'office
du juge dans la même veine le groupe
démocrate n'a pas soutenu en commission
l'adoption de l'article 1er a qui
propose de considérer le squat comme un
vol tout d'abord la création de ce délit
se fonde sur une notion floue et non
définie par le droit pénal celui de la
mauvaise foi l'adoption de ce nouvel
article dans la loi instaurerait une
présomption de culpabilité qui nous pose
problème et renverserait la charge de la
preuve cela engendre une assimilation
hasardeuse qui n'a pas lieu d'être sans
offrir de nouvelles réponses efficaces
pour les victimes nous soutiendrons
ainsi la proposition de réécriture pour
viser précisément l'occupation par une
personne n'ayant jamais été titulaire
d'un droit sur le local à usage
d'habitation
cet article exclurait de son champ les
logements constituants des domiciles
afin de ne pas empiéter sur le délit de
violation de domicile
vous l'aurez compris notre groupe
conscient des difficultés existantes sur
notre territoire pensent nécessaire de
renforcer le droit existant
cependant le groupe démocrate sera
vigilant et rigoureux quant à la
rédaction du texte final pour qu'il
respecte notre droit le droit pénal
comme le droit civil et qu'il ne tombe
pas sous la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel d'abord et parce qu'il
est de notre devoir de légiférer en
responsabilité pour les victimes de
quelques côtés qu'elle soit c'est en ce
sens que nous défendrons un amendement
pour ajuster les délais proposés par le
texte pour rendre pleinement efficace le
traitement des impayés locatifs tout en
apportant les garanties nécessaires à
l'accompagnement des locataires
préserver le droit de propriété tel que
décrit par les institutions donner aux
propriétaires des outils efficaces dans
la ligne droite de notre action depuis
2017 et offrir à chacun les moyens de
l'accompagnement nécessaires pour être
logés dignement telle est notre objectif
dans une grande majorité des cas la
détresse de ses affaires se révèle aussi
bien d'un côté que de l'autre soyons
juste et responsable je vous remercie
merci
monsieur député la parole est à Monsieur
Gérard le seul pour le groupe socialiste
est apparenté et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues votre proposition de loi
visant à protéger les logements contre
l'occupation illégale tente de répondre
à quelques rares affaires de squats qui
ont été récemment médiatisés 170
expulsions en 2021 il vise aussi les
litiges entre les locataires et les
propriétaires concernant les loyers en
fait cette proposition de loi fait trop
d'amalgame entre squat de domicile squat
de bâtiment vide et locataire en impayés
je tiens à vous faire part de la trévie
d'inquiétude de mon groupe socialiste à
parenté sur la confusion que ce texte
tente à développer entre les trois cas
de figures rappelées précédemment et en
assimilant injustement les locataires en
difficulté à des délinquants
la baisse des appels de votre précédent
quinquennat puis la réforme dite des
appels en temps réel qui a réduit les
périodes d'actualisation se sont
traduites rappelons-le par une
augmentation de l'insécurité des
locataires les plus modestes apprécier
premier coup de canif à la protection
des locataires modestes et sous couvert
d'une volonté de protection des
propriétaires vous stigmatisez ici une
fois encore une population socialement
précaire au lieu de créer des
protections nécessaires pour les
locataires et les bailleurs les lois
actuels la loi du 6 juillet 89 tendante
à améliorer des rapports locatifs est un
texte reconnu pour son équilibre dans la
relation contractuelle entre le
propriétaire et des locataires pourquoi
donc vouloir le bousculer vous remettez
en cause avec ce texte le corpus de
règles patiemment élaborées et
l'équilibre des parties tout en
protégeant le locataire car il
représente à partie réputée la plus
faible du contrat
il n'est cependant pas question de nier
la réalité le défaut de paiement d'un
locataire peut entraîner des difficultés
financières importantes du propriétaire
quand cette location s'apparente à un
complément de revenu notamment pour des
personnes retraitées comme il est
mentionné dans l'introduction du rapport
de cette ppm cette situation est
particulièrement difficile pour ses
propriétaires qui se trouvent démunis et
subissent des procédures judiciaires
souvent trop longues il n'est pas non
plus question de nier les potentiels
difficultés dans la relation
contractuelle entre le bailleur
propriétaire et le locataire mais ce
n'est pas par la stigmatisation et la
pénalisation des locataires les plus
précaires que nous pourrons protéger les
propriétaires et les locataires des
accidents de la vie vous proposez
notamment de réduire le délai
incompressible devant séparer de la
signation de l'audience dans la
procédure de défaut de paiement de 2 à 1
mois cette proposition se fait au mépris
de la finalité même de ce délai et de la
réalité de terrain ce délai est destiné
à permettre aux autorités préfectorales
de saisir l'organisme compétent dés par
le plan départemental d'action pour le
logement et d'hébergement des personnes
défavorisées afin qu'ils puissent
réaliser un diagnostic social et
financier transmis à l'audience et à la
commission de coordination des actions
de prévention des expulsions locatives
ce délai se font donc sur un travail
d'accompagnement social et de prise en
compte de la situation réelle du
locataire réduire ce délai fait courir
le risque de renier s'est accompagnement
social alors que les locataires en
difficulté ont besoin de cet
accompagnement voir de davantage
d'accompagnement en réalité votre
proposition ce qu'elle concerne le
défaut de paiement des locataires
manquent sa cible au lieu de stigmatiser
les locataires en difficulté il est
urgent d'augmenter leur protection comme
celle des bailleurs et de poursuivre la
réécriture de ce texte protéger des
locataires ne doit pas se faire au
détriment des propriétaires au contraire
protéger des locataires c'est aussi
protéger les propriétaires plutôt que
d'obliger la seule introduction
obligatoire d'une clause de résiliation
du bail dans le contrat de location vous
auriez pu proposer une obligation de
souscription l'assurance loyer impayés
sur le modèle de l'assurance locative et
améliorer les dispositifs existants
plutôt que de pointer du doigt les
ménages les plus en difficulté nous
continuons à réclamer une augmentation
des salaires à commencer par le SMIC et
l'ouverture d'une conférence nationale
sur les salaires plutôt que de pénaliser
voire criminaliser le défaut de paiement
nous proposons d'étendre le plafonnement
des loyers dans les zones tendues et
augmenter les aides au logement pour
répondre squat il conviendrait plutôt
d'augmenter les logements d'urgence pour
répondre mal logement il est urgent de
construire des logements sociaux de
lutter contre les locaux vides dans un
contexte de fortes inflation nos
concitoyens les plus modestes sont
particulièrement affectés dans une
période où la situation des locataires
est de plus en plus précaire notamment
avec des hausses de charge de chauffage
et d'énergie et l'augmentation des
loyers il serait dangereux de fragiliser
davantage la situation des locataires il
est à craindre que votre proposition de
loi
inutile sur le fond voire nocif dans son
application soit dans les mois à venir
une machine à créer des SDF comme le que
l'ensemble des associations de mal
logement à l'heure où la France compte 4
millions de mal logés 2,2 millions de
demandeurs HLM
77000 ménages DALO à reloger alors qu'il
y a 3,1 millions de logements vides
votre texte se trompe de cible c'est la
crise du logement qu'il faut combattre
et non ces victimes la concertation
parlementaire que les ministres comme
certains orateurs de groupe ont salué
tout à l'heure n'a finalement réuni que
les bancs de la droite pour ces raisons
et en l'état actuel du texte nous
voterons contre merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal
pour le groupe horizon et à parenté et
pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous examinons ce soir
un texte que de nombreux Français
attendent le droit à la propriété à son
respect comme la confiance en la justice
sont des piliers de notre société chaque
citoyen doit se sentir en sécurité dans
son domicile et avoir l'assurance que
nul ne peut le déposséder le dépouiller
du jour au lendemain
son point volontairement des mots forts
car le choc et l'incompréhension que
connaissent les Français ainsi mises à
la porte de chez eux non pas pour des
raisons dont il serait la cause mais par
la faute d'un délit commis par autrui
sont immenses nous ne cherchons pas à
remettre en question le droit au
logement opposable le droit pour chacun
d'à avoir un toit mais précisément à le
renforcer il ne saurait y avoir une loi
pour les occupants légaux et une autre
qui protégerait les délinquants il n'y
en a qu'une qui doit veiller à l'intérêt
général avec cohérence
la cohérence nous Appache justement de
renforcer les sanctions pénales qui sont
appliquées au squatteur à ceux qui
entrent ou se maintiennent de manière
illicite et par voie de fait dans un
logement d'autrui à ce jour quelqu'un
qui évacue soi-même cela a été dit par
la force un squatteur de chez lui risque
plus que le délinquant lui-même ce n'est
pas acceptable
nous soutenons ainsi la disposition du
texte qui remet les peines en cohérence
et nous avons choisi d'ajouter une
sanction supplémentaire pour ceux qui
incitent et facilitent le squat nous
pouvons en effet trouver très facilement
sur internet des modes d'emploi des
guides pour entrer et se maintenir
illégalement dans un bien cela n'est pas
acceptable lorsque l'occupation est
délictuelle il faut pouvoir poursuivre
ceux qui ont aidé à la Commission de
cette infraction sur ce texte le groupe
horizon s'attachera particulièrement à
proposer des mesures qui visent à
renforcer le pouvoir des mères face à
des occupations illicites générant des
troubles à l'ordre public et qui abrite
parfois comme je l'ai vu à Nice des
activités illégales pour reprendre une
expression connue et pardon pour sa
trivialité les mers sont en effet comme
vous le savez apporter d'engueulade et
c'est vers eux et les élus locaux en
général que les occupants lésés les
riverains se tournent et ces deux qu'ils
attendent des solutions
or ces élus n'ont pas aujourd'hui de
véritables pouvoirs d'action les
amendements que notre groupe a déposé
propose que les mers puissent prendre
part à la procédure décrite à l'article
38 de la loi DALO selon plusieurs
critères cumulatifs dont le constat
d'une occupation illicite générant des
troubles et la prise de contact avec
l'occupant légal et le dépôt de plainte
le maire pourra saisir le préfet lui
demander une mise en demeure
d'évacuation des lieux dans ces cas
d'occupation sauvage et illégales nous
souhaitons donc renforcer la loi
existante et les réponses
administratives et pénales à apporter
aux citoyens
là ne va pas sans l'autre les Français
ne peuvent pas adhérer à des dispositifs
de protection des plus démunis
absolument nécessaires surtout dans la
période que nous traversons et accepter
que le squat reste insuffisamment
prévenu et puni je tiens donc à saluer
le remarquable travail du rapporteur
Guillaume kasbariian qui poursuit son
œuvre de fond et de proposition dont
nous voyons aujourd'hui la qualité des
résultats nous soutenons les
dispositions apportées en commission
comme par exemple le fait qu'un
propriétaire n'aura plus à entretenir
son bien illégalement occupé mais
également la prolongation d'une
expérimentation sur l'occupation
temporaire des logements cet équilibre
entre l'accès temporaire des biens
inoccupés qui peut répondre aux besoins
d'hébergement et le soulagement apporté
aux occupants légaux aux propriétaires
victimes nous semblent aller dans le bon
sens proposant d'ailleurs de faciliter
la charge de la preuve qui incombe à
l'occupant légal qui doit démontrer que
le logement occupé bien le sien en
permettant au préfet de solliciter en
urgence des vérifications auprès
notamment l'administration fiscale
conscient que ce sujet a été travaillé
en profondeur avec des argumentaires
approfondis le groupe Horizon est
apparenté ce fessier se félicite pardon
de la cohérence et de l'efficacité qui
résulteront de l'adoption de ce texte de
votre endoc en sa faveur et espérons de
nos débats qui permettront d'aboutir un
texte indiquant clairement la direction
souhaitée la propriété est un droit
inviolable et sacré mais aussi un droit
naturel et imprescriptible ce soir c'est
aussi de ce sujet dont il est question
merci
ma parole est un monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous voilà réunis sur un
sujet grave qui vous le savez révolte
bon nombre de nos concitoyens
l'occupation illicite des logements je
ne vais pas revenir sur des exemples qui
ont été abondamment cités un véritable
enfer et une inversion des valeurs
complètes qui vivent chaque année de
nombreux Français c'est pourquoi j'avais
déposé trois propositions de loi en 2015
en 2018 en 2020 pour mettre en place une
procédure d'urgence pour durcir les
peines pour prendre en compte les
résidences secondaires autant que les
résidences principales heureusement à
force de persuasion la loi du 7 décembre
2020 a permis il faut le reconnaître une
réelle accélération des procédures
d'expulsion votre proposition de loi
quant à elle va dans le bon sens elle
renforce les dispositions durcissant la
réponse pénale en intégrant un logement
non meublé en libérant l'O d'entretien
du bailleur et c'est important et en
définissant l'occupation sans droit ni
titre suite à des amendements comme un
vol pour une fois que nous sommes
d'accord et c'est si rare j'aurais
mauvaise grâce pour des raisons
politiques à ne pas la voter
malheureusement votre proposition de loi
c'est un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
voter des lois c'est bien les appliquer
c'est mieux or malheureusement votre
gouvernement ne donne pas les moyens
suffisants aux préfectures ni aux
tribunaux pour passer aux actes trop
souvent les préfets reportent des
expulsions et nos concitoyens
s'indignent de voir les squatteurs
pavanés et nargués les propriétaires
dans les logements
occupés c'est pourquoi dans mes
propositions de loi je demandais aux
maires d'être davantage associé aux
procédures parce que les mères
connaissent leur terrain quant à la
procédure judiciaire aux procédures
judiciaires devraient-je dire civil ou
pénal faut-il encore que les tribunaux
et la capacité de traiter les affaires
alors
ceux qui sont en extrême difficulté
sociale ne doivent pas être sacrifiés
par une accélération excessive des
procédures et pour vraiment réconcilier
et pour vraiment réconcilier
propriétaire et locataires
garder un équilibre satisfaisant il faut
surtout traiter la cause des tensions
c'est à dire la grave crise du logement
que connaît notre pays et qui est la
conséquence de votre politique oui votre
majorité a sacrifié le secteur de la
construction même le journal du monde
même le monde du premier février 2022
s'en était mû rappelant que vous aviez
réalisé 15 milliards d'économies sur ce
secteur lors du premier quinquennat
votre politique de gribouille en matière
de logement social à essorer les
finances des bailleurs sociaux en
imposant d'ailleurs la fameuse taxe pour
compenser la baisse des aPL l'état oui
l'État qui donne des leçons de logements
social en permanence et les grands
discours nos subventionne quasiment plus
la création de logements sociaux et je
peux vous en témoigner pour un programme
de 7 logements que nous venons de faire
à la ville de la ville de Hyères 7
logements un coup de 942000 euros l'aide
de l'État a été de 20000 euros sur 900 -
2 % depuis 10 ans chaque année les
dépenses de l'État en matière de
logement social diminue aujourd'hui le
logement social repose sur les
financements des collectivités locales
que par ailleurs vous avez asphy avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
conduisant les communes augmentées la
taxe foncière pour se rattraper
pénalisant d'autant plus les
propriétaires qui investissent un
bailleur social me confier récemment
qu'il a 15 ans il pouvait lancer une
opération avec seulement 15% de fonds
propres aujourd'hui lui en faut
25%. ajoutez à cela les obligations de
rénovation énergétique qui doit financer
vous comprendrez aisément pourquoi le
nombre de logements mis en chantier est
insuffisant sans parler bien sûr de la
crise énergétique qui en refusant de
revenir un prix national de
l'électricité va paupériser un peu plus
les français malgré le bouclier et
encore plus les copropriétés et les
bailleurs en définitive ce n'est pas une
proposition de loi qui traitera le mal à
la racine il est en changer largement de
politique du logement pour que chaque
Français puisse trouver un toit et vivre
dignement merci monsieur
la parole est à monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je voulais
profiter de l'instant pour répondre à
quelques-unes des interrogations et des
interpellations que j'ai reçues monsieur
peut vous avez dit que la proposition de
toi elle est affaiblir le droit au
logement mais en réalité la majorité a
toujours mené une politique ambitieuse
sur le sujet qui a mis en place
l'encadrement des loyers c'est la
majorité qui a mis en place le
plafonnement de la hausse des loyers cet
été dernier c'est la majorité qui a fait
l'extension de visale c'est la majorité
qui a mis des obligations aux
propriétaires en termes de rénovation
thermique des logements pour éviter les
passoires thermiques c'est la majorité
et donc on peut je crois faire du en
même temps monsieur peut on peut avoir
une politique du logement qui est
ambitieuse qui est protectrice vis-à-vis
des locataires et en même temps faire
respecter le droit de propriété et c'est
exactement cette recherche de en même
temps que nous essayons de réaliser
je voudrais dire au groupe idiote et
émotionnel et et à Monsieur à Monsieur
Lenormand que que je souhaitais les
remercier pour leur travail constructif
en commission des affaires économiques
et saluer les propositions de la
succession de Monsieur nigelin sur le
sujet il y a des éléments qu'on a repris
en commission des affaires économiques
et je pense qu'on pourrait
éventuellement en reprendre certains au
cours de la discussion remercier Paul
midi bien sûr du groupe renaissance pour
son soutien sans faille et également les
ajouts qui ont été menés par le groupe
Renaissance au cours de la discussion je
pense notamment à la question des
marchands de sommeil sur lequel a
renforcement des sanctions a été portée
trois ans de prison 45000 euros d'amende
et également la question de la
prolongation de cette expérimentation de
la loi Elan qui avait été portée par des
collègues je pense à Michael nogal je
pense à Nicolas Desmoulins que vous
proposez de prolonger j'espère que la
discussion permettait d'envisager une
pérennisation définitive je voudrais
dire à Madame Grangier
du rassemblement national vous avez dit
le texte peut s'inspirer du texte de
Marine Le Pen en 20 je dois vous dire
que non pour trois raisons la première
c'est que nous avons traité la question
des squats en 2020 à travers la loi asap
et
donc nous n'avons pas attendu de la
proposition de loi de Madame Le Pen pour
nous intéresser à la question des squats
et répondre à des situations difficiles
c'est l'article 73 de la loi ASAP que
nous avons porté qui a permis
d'améliorer la procédure Express
d'expulsion des squatteurs qui ne
fonctionnaient pas qui n'avaient pas été
modifié depuis 2007 pour la rendre
effective la rendre effective en mettant
des délais ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant en incluant la résidence
secondaire ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant en demandant aux préfectures de
répondre quand c'est une situation de
squat et on l'obligeant à répondre en
autorisant des ayants droits à utiliser
cette procédure Express toutes ces
mesures là elles ont intégré elles ont
été intégrées dans la dans la loi ASAP
c'est à dire préalablement à toute
proposition de loi de Marine Le Pen et
je dois dire que sur ce sujet là la PPL
qui vous avait déposé le 2 novembre
c'est à dire postérieurement à celle que
le groupe Renaissance a déposé ne traite
que de la question des squats mais ne
parle pas de la question des impayés et
donc je crois que on ne parle pas de
toute cette zone qui est celle des loca
des locataires qui se retrouvent en
situation d'impayés de façon prolongée
pendant des années que nous nous avons
décidé d'aborder parce que il s'agit
toutes les affaires récentes médiatiques
c'est des cas d'un pays locatif pierre
et Maryse à Marseille c'est deux ans
d'un pays Mégane dans la zone c'est 15
mois d'un pays et donc ce sont ces
affaires-là que nous allons résoudre
avec notre proposition de loi je tenais
juste à préciser qu'il y a eu depuis
2020 18 propositions de loi sur le sujet
venant de divers bancs sur cette
émission madame Simonet vous avez par
oui je je dois saluer votre anaphore
dehors expulsion je dois juste vous
rappeler vous avez fait toutes les
auditions effectivement avec moi
quasiment toutes la seule que vous
n'avez pas faite c'est celle des
victimes de squatteurs et d'impayés
c'est vrai c'est la seule que vous
n'avez pas mené avec moi par contre oui
mais les avocats ne sont pas des
victimes madame Simonet en revanche vous
savez bien que la procédure actuelle
elle est extrêmement longue si vous avez
un impayé en janvier 2023 vous vous
retrouvez ensuite donc vous vous
retrouvez dans une situation d'impayés
bon vous êtes le propriétaire rappelle
amiable commandement de payer qui arrive
en février 2023 vous avez ensuite deux
mois minimum d'attente avril 2023 avant
d'arriver à l'assignation en justice
ensuite éventuellement vous aurez une
audience en juin 2023 mais ça dépend des
tribunaux parce que vous avez des délais
de justice qui font qu'en juin 2023 vous
n'êtes pas sûr de l'avoir ensuite vous
avez éventuellement un constat de
résiliation avec un commandement de
quitter les lieux qui peut être délivré
mais pas forcément parce qu'il peut y
avoir des reports d'audience parce que
derrière il peut avoir une aide
juridictionnelle donc c'est encore
plusieurs mois d'attendre et puis après
vous arrivez aux demandes de la concours
aux demandes de concours de la force
publique qui l'a encore peut prendre
plusieurs mois et vous arrivez enfin
éventuellement à l'expulsion des lieux
s'il n'y a pas eu de délai accordé par
le juge et ce bien évidemment après la
traviale si j'avais proposé une
procédure qui permettait top chrono en
un mois de dire vous avez un impayé
dehors expulsion pour reprendre votre
anaphore là je pourrais dire
effectivement que c'est excessif mais ça
n'est pas le cas nous ne supprimons
aucune des étapes de la procédure nous
accélérons les délais entre chacune des
étapes d'une procédure que nous
respections parfaitement donc oui nous
allons raccourcir les délais mais nous
ne sommes pas dans une procédure Express
qui peut exister dans beaucoup d'autres
démocraties européennes sur lesquelles
les jeux sont beaucoup plus rapides nous
sommes dans le lieu en même temps et
dans l'équilibre encore une fois pour
reprendre cette expression
madame genvarjeune à saluer votre
travail celui de votre groupe sur le
sujet et les nombreuses propositions de
loi que vous avez déjà portées vous avez
cité celle de Monsieur Aubert il y en a
eu d'autres également au sein de votre
groupe je tenais à saluer l'esprit
constructif avec lequel vous avez abordé
cette proposition de loi en travaillant
avec moi sur le sujet en proposant des
amendements que nous avons essayé de
faire atterrir ensemble je comprends que
il y a eu sur certains bancs certaines
interrogations sur l'écriture de
certains de ses amendements je pense que
la discussion que nous pouvons avoir en
séance permettra de clarifier certaines
rédactions vous portez vous même
d'ailleurs des propositions
d'amélioration rédactionnelle qui
permettent d'éviter des billets
constitutionnels qui permettent de
clarifier le quantum des Pen et qui
permettent de faire en sorte que ça vole
et que ça soit opérationnel mais je
tenais vraiment à saluer votre votre
esprit constructif en tout cas sur cette
proposition de loi et je suis sûr que
vous ne regretterez pas que nous
puissions voter cette proposition de loi
ensemble je tenais à dire également au
modem merci pour le soutien que vous
avez témoigné à cette proposition de loi
en commission merci également pour les
avancer que que certains ont porté
certains d'entre vous veulent même aller
plus loin sur certains sujets je pense à
la procédure du 38 DALO que certains
voudraient étendre et là encore je pense
que sur les questions de réécriture on
peut trouver un atterrissage qui
convient à tous monsieur le seul dupez
vous avez dit c'est la crise du logement
qu'il faut combattre mais je crois
précisément monsieur le seul que avec
cette proposition de loi on ne fait pas
autre chose en réalité la crise du
logement on a une on a un tarissement de
l'offre de logement on n'a pas assez
d'offre de logements ce qui fait que les
prix augmentent et ce qui fait que vous
avez une pénurie de logement si on veut
encourager l'offre si on veut encourager
l'investissement locatif si on veut
encourager des propriétaires à mettre en
location des biens qui aujourd'hui
parfois se retrouvent soit de vacances
soit loué à travers Airbnb ou du meublé
touristique il faut pouvoir apporter un
minimum de sécurité en cas de problème
si aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec des
tonnes de papier de garant de caution
qui sont demandés aux candidats à la
location c'est je crois précisément
parce que les propriétaires essaient de
se couvrir vis-à-vis du risque d'impayés
et donc je crois qu'il faut pas opposer
crise du logement et ce que nous faisons
actuellement nous essayons précisément
de rassurer les propriétaires en leur
disant n'ayez pas peur de louer n'ayez
pas peur de louer à des Français de
façon standard sans faire du Moby
touristique sans faire du Airbnb n'ayez
pas peur parce qu'en cas d'un pays vous
n'aurez pas des années d'un pays vous
aurez derrière une procédure qui sera un
peu plus accélérée tout en restant
respectueuse de l'ensemble des étapes je
tenais à saluer le groupe horizon et
Monsieur Pradal merci encore une fois
pour votre soutien en commission et
votre soutien répété à la tribune je
sais que vous portez des amendements
notamment sur la question du des maires
de façon à aider l'application du 38
DALO en se disant que le maire peut en
tant qu'apj éventuellement constaté lui
aussi le squat au même titre qu'un OPJ
au même titre que que la police et la
gendarmerie je crois que c'est des
amendements qui vont aller dans le bon
sens et qui vont permettre d'atterrir
vous portez également des dispositifs
qui vont permettre de s'attaquer à des
choses absolument scandaleuses que sont
par exemple le guide du bon squatteur je
le ramènerai demain pour pouvoir en
parler mais vous avez aujourd'hui des
guides voilà le squat de A à Z qui
derrière donne des instructions des
éléments qui permettent à chacun et à
des délinquants en réalité de choisir
son propriétaire de mettre l'eau
l'électricité à tous les étages de etc
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
laisser passer ça c'est une disposition
qui a d'ailleurs été très regardée par
les sénateurs dont je salue le travail
et qui ont toujours été constant sur le
sujet et je pense que là encore ça peut
être un travail de co-construction
assemblée et Sénat pour sanctionner plus
durement celles et ceux qui font
l'apologie du squat et qui derrière
donnent des instructions et de façon à
contourner la loi et exploiter toutes
les ficelles pour durer et faire durer
le squat voilà ce que je pouvais vous
dire et je ne répondrai pas à Monsieur
tâcher parce que je pense que tout ce
qui est excessif est insignifiant et
donc je pense que je pense que nous
pouvons directement rentrer dans le
détail des articles je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la
discussion générale et close j'appelle
maintenant dans le texte de la
commission les articles de la
proposition de loi nous en venons aux
articles deux terres à 5 qui sont
examinés en priorité sur l'article de
terre plusieurs inscrits Monsieur
Frédéric maillot
avant de devenir élu de la République je
travaillais dans une boutique solidarité
de la Fondation abépière où j'ai
accueillis des personnes sans logement
qui dormaient dans un bâtiment où une
maison abandonnée pour tenter je dis
bien tenter de passer une nuit
tranquille loin de la violence de la rue
l'abbé Pierre a donc été mon patron
pendant 11 ans et l'abbé Pierre disait
qu'on ne pleure pas devant des chiffres
toutefois laissez-moi vous rappeler
quelques chiffres qui ont déjà été
rappelés au sein de cette émission le
115 refuse un hébergement d'urgence à
6000 personnes dont 1700 enfants que 4
millions de Français sont en situation
de mal logement et 110 000 chez moi à la
Réunion que 623 personnes d'hommes et de
femmes meurent à la rue chaque année ça
vous fait rire monsieur le rapporteur
pas nous que le temps d'attendre pour un
logement social et de 22,7 mois cette
loi qui s'empresse d'envoyer les plus
précaires devant le juge au lieu de
diminuer le temps d'attente pour obtenir
un logement social cette loi qui ouvre
la porte à la prison plutôt que d'ouvrir
la porte un logement digne aux Français
vous confirmez que l'absurdistan est
bien la capitale de la macronie cette
loi qui est une agression à ceux et
celles qui ont trouvé refuge dans un
bâtiment inoccupé que l'État a failli à
sa mission qui est de loger les citoyens
cette loi envoie un message clair net et
précis tu veux être logé et Ben et du
blé laissez-moi vous rappeler le slogan
de la Fondation obépière soyons humains
cher rapporteur la pauvreté n'est pas
une tare soyez humain et revoyez le
comptoir le contour de votre de votre
loi
merci la parole est à Monsieur juste une
chou pour le groupe Renaissance et pour
deux minutes
alors nous commençons l'examen détaillé
du texte et article par article c'est
important de préciser ce qui sera notre
philosophie qui a déjà été rappelé par
notre collègue kasbarian et l'idée que
nous poursuivons contrairement à ce qui
a pu être dit tout à l'heure dans la
discussion générale c'est que nous
voulons défendre les petits
propriétaires puisque les petits
propriétaires comme ils se définissent
d'ailleurs souvent ainsi sont des
Français souvent de la classe moyenne
qui ont hérité d'un bien ou qui ont
acheté une maison et un appartement pour
investir et pour se préparer
régulièrement également leur retraite et
garder des revenus
complémentaires pas plus tard il y a
quelques jours comme beaucoup d'entre
vous j'organisais une permanence dans ma
circonscription dans mon bureau et j'ai
reçu deux de mes concitoyens qui avait
insisté pour que j'allais reçoivent
rapidement parce qu'il savait que nous
allons à Lyon étudier ce texte et il
voulait me faire part de leur de leur
témoignages
c'était deux Français
fonctionnaires dans les collectivités
qui n'ont rien des riches que nos
collègues de la gauche avant ont pu
dénoncer qui avait acheté un bien
immobilier pour s'assurer une retraite
dans quelques années et puis pour aider
les enfants pour leur prochaine études
et ils ont dû subir des locataires qui
ont refusé de payer le loyer et ils ont
utilisé ces termes ces Français qui sont
venus me voir c'est tout simplement du
vol
c'est moi et c'est moi et c'est moi de
loyer qui nous n'ont pas été dû et dont
nous ne savons toujours pas d'ailleurs
si nous les retrouverons un jour or le
vol chers collègues nous devrions le
savoir nous qui sommes législateur c'est
illégal et donc notre objectif c'est
bien de rétablir l'autorité dans notre
pays et rétablir l'autorité ces rétablir
le droit de propriété qui est un droit
inviolable et sacré comme long écrit il
y a un peu plus de 200 ans ce qui nous
ont précédés dans cette émission merci
Monsieur delogu pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires c'est
l'histoire d'un couple
de jeunes de 25 ans avec deux enfants en
bas âge le jeudi 12 avril 2012 à 14h ils
sont expulsés de leur logement par un
jugement cette famille est perdue le
couple est détruit le parcours du
combattant s'enchaîne pour la maman et
le papa pour essayer de retrouver un
logement le père n'assume plus son rôle
le couple se sépare les enfants perdent
leurs repères
10 ans passent et en 2022 après avoir
enchaîné des événements tragiques le
père ne voit toujours pas ses enfants de
peur d'être jugé pour ne pas avoir
réussi à subvenir aux besoins de sa
famille cette famille c'est celle d'un
parlementaire assis sur ses bancs cette
famille c'est la mienne
je vous en supplie ne perdez jamais de
vue que le droit fondamental au logement
ne peut être mise au même niveau que la
rentabilité financière d'un bailleur
cette loi inverse les normes le produit
de la location d'un bien deviendrait
plus important que le droit à
l'hébergement ce qui révèle du droit du
commerce ne peut être comparé à celle
qui relève de la loi fondamentale dans
un pays où 4 millions de nos concitoyens
sont en situation de mal logement tandis
que 3 millions de logements entre dans
la qualification de vacances les comptes
ne sont pas bons les priorités ne sont
pas bonnes l'initiateur de cette loi
s'est lancé peut-être par des
démagogie dans un espèce de croisade
pour un droit à la propriété qui
supplanterait le droit de tout un chacun
à dormir au chaud moi tout ce que je
vous demande c'est de ne pas voter cette
loi merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la propriété est un droit inviolable et
sacré c'était la promesse du constituant
de 1789 pourtant depuis des années cette
promesse est mise à mal quand elle n'est
pas totalement bafouée des situations
intolérables quand on sait que la
plupart des propriétaires ne détiennent
qu'un seul logement et que pour un tiers
d'entre eux il s'agit de retraités pour
qui le logement constitue un complément
de revenus indispensable compte tenu du
faible niveau de leur pension la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui va dans le bon sens elle
procède un rééquilibrage des droits
entre locataire et propriétaire c'est
nécessaire absolument nécessaire une
mesure de justice sociale et qui ne
concernant rien tous ceux qui
s'acquittent scrupuleusement de leur
loyer pour cela elle durcit les
sanctions pénales dorénavant les squator
en cours rond 3 ans de prison et 45000
euros d'amende elle clarifie les notions
utilisées pour caractériser l'infraction
de squat et devrait mettre votre fin à
ses brèches juridiques dans lesquelles
s'engouffre les squatteurs cette
proposition de loi aurait aussi pu
donner de nouveaux moyens aux bailleurs
pour qu'ils puissent agir en cas de
loyer impayés pour cela il était
initialement prévu un délit d'occupation
sans droit ni titre en violation d'une
décision de justice du logement d'autrui
quel dommage de n'être pas aller
jusqu'au bout en revanche elle sécurise
la portée de la clause de résiliation
dans le contrat de bail en la rendant
obligatoire et elle revient sur la
capacité du juge à en suspendre
l'exécution sans parler des réductions
des délais dans les procédures
contentieuses des points positifs même
s'il serait souhaitable de simplifier la
procédure d'expulsion pour la rendre
encore plus efficace et bien sûr plus
rapide j'ai déposé un amendement ce sens
et j'espère qu'il sera accueilli
favorablement je vous remercie
merci madame la députée alors je vais
lever la séance et nous examinerons
demain les amendements donc prochaine
séance demain à 15h avec les questions
gouvernement la suite de la proposition
de loi visant à protéger les logements
contre l'occupation ici la science est
élevée